Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that
are gone. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a fog champ, keep a forehead, bible thumb, twitch emotes. I remember typing Dan's game,
forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish. Life was easy, spamming all the time,
TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel
you're not alone. Cap a fog champ, keep a forehead, bible thumb, twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy emotes reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I missed emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a fog champ, keep a forehead, bible thumb, twitch emotes.
Bei uns zu posten, allerdings ist das in dem Channel wahrscheinlich nicht so gut angekommen.
Gibt es da einen Online-Generator wie früher?
Genau, so ein Ding hast du jetzt auch in Teams drin, da habe ich mich ein bisschen lustig
gemacht über die Leute, die bei uns Software deployen, wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Eigentlich überhaupt nichts Schlimmes, ich wollte mal den Meme-Generator in Teams testen.
Ich wollte auch schon Twitch-Emotes rein, MonkaS-Bildchen habe ich auch gepostet, aber
da reagiert keiner drauf, die sind da glaube ich einfach zu oldschool und zu steif dafür
auf sowas zu reagieren. Ich fand es eigentlich ganz lustig, wenn man das in unsere Software
deploy-Channel postet, aber zu viele Boomer wahrscheinlich, so viele Boomer zu wenig Zoomer.
Aber nachdem wir ja in der Finanzbranche tätig sind, haben wir einige Boomer am Start, der
Untergang ist ja auf dem Weg, immer gleich mit Weebsperm im Team, nee, wenn ich mit
Weebsperm im Team empfange, dann ist MonkaS Abmalung ist raus, das kann ich nicht machen,
aber normale Sachen kann. Ich glaube es dauert ja nicht lang, weil es ist einfach zu modern
für uns, diese Meme-Generator Funktion, die ist zu modern für uns. Ich glaube, das dauert
einen Monat, dann ist die Funktion abgeschaltet, falls man sie abschalten kann. Wenn man sie
abschalten kann, dann ist sie bald weg, die sind bei uns nicht 2020 genug dafür. Hey Max,
was, oh Moment, ich muss, Sekunden Leute, ich hab mein Better Twitch TV deinstalliert
und FFZ bei mir auf dem Vorschau-Rechner installiert, ich muss jetzt erstmal einschalten, dass
die anderen an mich wieder Highlighted werden. Wie geht denn das hier? Chat, Chat, Highlight,
Highlight an mich, mich erwähnen, erwähnen, Moment, wie geht denn das jetzt? Ich muss
mal kurz, weil sonst seh ich nicht, hier, Zuschauerkarten, aktiviere das Öffnen, fuck,
ich weiß nicht, wo ich mich selbst hervorhebe, weil deswegen seh ich die Chat-Nachrichten
nicht, die er an mich schreibt. Chat, Filterung hier, Nachrichten hervorheben, die mich markieren,
können wir mal ausprobieren, spammt mal bitte eine Runde n' Wubblors im Chat und dann gucken
wir mal, ob das funktioniert, ob ich jetzt wieder sehe. Ja, funktioniert wunderbar, perfekt,
dankeschön, nice, jetzt, jetzt wird natürlich, jetzt kann sich jetzt keiner nehmen lassen
eine Runde, was hältst du von Mail Globe? Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert, keine Ahnung,
jetzt wo ich das Logo sehe, ich hab das schon mal gesehen, aber ich kann dazu überhaupt
nix sagen, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, nicht ausprobiert. Twitch-Integration und
dann Lul-W-Spam, ja, das wäre gut, wenn Teams eine Twitch-Integration hätte. Die Mitarbeiter
zufrieden, dann hat sich dann GIFs extrem verbessert, ey, man glaubt gar nicht, wie
viel Einfluss so kleine Kleinigkeiten haben. So, ich glaub ich hab sonst nix mehr übersehen,
wenn ich was übersehen hab, müsste ich das grad noch mal schreiben. Ey Max, was hältst
du von Mail Globe? Hab ich doch grad gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert.
Wär da Teams-Emoat? Oh, das wär natürlich was. Die eine Sache bei Teams ist ein bisschen
merkwürdig, man kann integrieren, also das Ding hat ganz viele Plugins, ja, also was
man Jira integrieren, Ticket-System integrieren, aber meistens nicht mit den lokalen Installationen,
sondern nur mit der Cloud, was sehr merkwürdig ist. Okay, also, komm Leute, wir gucken mal,
was Brutal FPS Masterpiece Created by OnePerson. Was ist das? Ach, das doch, das haben wir
doch schon mal gesehen. Das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen. Das ist dieses Ding, wo
sie jetzt einen zweiten Teil von produzieren wollen, mit mehr Geld. Ubi, du hast so viel
Plagg, der so hat gespielt, ey. Das ist die einzige Community, ja, die ich kenne, die
auf diesem Kram hängen geblieben ist. So, wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal, zum Beispiel
Oles, so alt ist das ganz schön, ja, alt, Plagg derzeit immer noch so toxic, keine Ahnung,
ich hab das schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gespielt. Das Einzige, was ich aktuell spiele,
ist das hier, und das ist auch hauptsächlich der Grund, warum ich in letzter Zeit so wenig
streame, weil ich gerade den übelsten Season-Crime mache in Path of Exile. Quasi jeden Tag, wenn
ich heimkomme, bis ich ins Bett gehe, mache ich Maps oder irgendwelchen anderen sinnlosen
Content. Streamen doch, das ist langweilig zuzugucken. Also Path of Exile zuzugucken
ist übelst lame. Ich guck's mir auch nicht an. Das Einzige, wo ich mir Path of Exile
mal auf Twitch angeguckt hab, ist wo letztens diese ZDPS League oder so gestartet ist, weil
ich mir einfach mal angucken wollte, wie es die Pros hinkriegen, einen guten Leaguestart
hinzulegen. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass es die richtig guten Leute, die schaffen das
quasi in 2-3 Stunden so Endgame-mäßig am Start zu sein, oder zumindest in die Richtung,
nach 4 Stunden quasi schon ganz guten Clearspeed, wo ich mir so denke, ok, da hab ich 2 Tage
für gebraucht, oder 3 Tage, nicht so weit war. Mit Techtalk nebenbei, ja, das, man muss
bei Path of Exile, wenn man Maps macht, ein bisschen konzentriert sein. Also man kann
nicht komplett, also vor allem wenn man Maps macht, die sich lohnen, man kann nicht komplett,
wobei ich Spiel Summoner, ich kann auch vom Bildschirm weg gucken. Diesmal ist das Essen
das zweite von rechts. Ich sag euch Leute, Essen ist immer oben rechts. Die haben schon
irgendwelche Analysen durchgeführt, dass Essen immer oben rechts sein muss. Ok, komm,
wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns zum einen Stichwort MW2-Video. Richtig olles MW2-Video. Hier,
da war's Leute, habt ihr's gesehen? Deswegen war die Map, deswegen, wegen dem Bild, was
hier oben hing, war die Map kurzzeitig gesperrt. Erinnert sich noch jemand. Ich bin ja immer
noch begeistert, dass so viele Leute den Kram spielen. Ich mein, das Game ist wie alt jetzt?
2013 oder so? Wann kam das raus? 2010? 2010, oder? Was auch erst nach vielen Jahren. Jaja,
2010, das ist zu alt. Warum spielen das überhaupt noch Leute? MW2 ist ein richtiges Rage-Game
gewesen, weil es so viele Sachen gab, woran du sterben konntest. Achso, er darf ja nicht
messern, er muss ja USP'en. Ach, er hat doch gemessert. Ich hab extra leiser gemacht.
Oh, achso, deswegen, weil er ins Raum schreit. Oh, ich muss meine E-Maus ein bisschen größer
machen. Ach, perfekt. Das ist auch einer seiner Lieblingspositionen hier. Das hat er
schon irgendwie in 10 Gameplays gehabt, woran er da was- ne, nicht was- Villa? Nee, oh fuck.
Estate! Nee, meine Güte, nee. Estate war die CS-Map. Wie heißt die Map nochmal? Doch
Estate, oder? Als Controller gegen die Wand geschmissen. Ah, die Gegner sind auch schon
immer noch, immer noch richtig blindert. Halt Konsole. Ja, und? Was macht der da oben?
Kann man deine E-Maus irgendwo herunterladen? Hä? So wie bei allen anderen Channels auch.
Oder du meinst in Hi-Res? Hast du dir schon Wolzen-Wolzen oder wie man das ausspricht
angeschaut? Ähm, ja, allerdings, ähm, warte mal. Allerdings, ähm, haben mich die Bugs
ein bisschen abgeschreckt und dass es wohl online nicht richtig läuft, weil ich, wenn
ich so ein Spiel spiele, dann wenn schon nur online und es noch total unklar ist, wie das
Endgame wird und es, es, also ich meine in Path of Exile gibt es auch total viele unbalanced
Builds, aber da gibt es halt welche, die sind, die sind komplett broken. Du musst einfach
nur die richtigen paar Skills auswählen und du machst quasi zehntausende Damage und das
auch ohne jetzt wirklich sonderlich großes Gier, was ich bisher gesehen habe. Also ich
warte mal ab, wie das Ganze, Ganze wird. Zumal ich sagen muss, dass ich halt aktuell, was
Path of Exile angeht, weil echt viel Spaß dran habe, weil ich bin ja noch recht neu,
ich meine, ich hab das zwar schon lange gespielt, mal vor, vor, vor fünf Jahren oder so, schon
ewig her, aber das Coole ist, es gibt so viel krass neues Zeug, du brauchst eigentlich
eins, zwei komplette Leaks, bis du überhaupt durchblickst, was es alles gibt. Das ist so
krass mittlerweile, was du in Path of Exile, was du alles machen kannst und wo überall
irgendwie noch was drin steckt. Ich glaube, das ist eines der komplexesten, so Hack and
Slash, oder nee, das ist das komplexeste Action-RPG-Hack and Slash-Game, was es gibt. Ist Stadia
ja schon dead? Ist verdächtlich ruhig um Stadia, ja. Jetzt kam ja diese, oh das müssen wir
im Stream übrigens ausprobieren Leute. Nvidia Game Stream wollte ich mal ausprobieren im
stream und nicht geig geig geifers nau heißt nicht gemmsteam gemmsteam ist das lokale
stadia wird abkappen ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt oder
haha ne ich hab ich hab nur eins in high res außerdem emotes brauchst ja maximal 128 x 128
das reicht für emotes haben die auch negative latenz die haben rtx on
wie pay flow da oben steht wie werden skirmars leute
koopa silenced usb no chopper no chopper was ist das erste was ich sehen in heli
leute chopper ist in heli chopper gunner ist der elfer kill streak ja ich weiß
dass er chopper gunner meint aber wenn man mal ganz genau sind bedeutet no chopper
natürlich auch dass er kein pay flow nimmt ihr müsst mir das nicht erklären
wie das spiel was ich hab das lang genug gespielt ich weiß dass er chopper gunner meint ich dachte
auch dass der harry hat pay flow oder harry a c 130 weil der könnte der könnte genauso gut
harry a c 130 verwenden und es wäre easy es wäre überhaupt kein unterschied zwischen zwischen
chopper gunner und so also du musst einfach du musst auf bed at which tv und ffz gehen da
kannst du dir anzeigen lassen welche emotes ich auf dem channel flow 690 der benutzer hat
bereits sieben monate abonniert alter jetzt gehts aber los ja ich wollte eigentlich den antrücken
und max wie läuft bei dir mit der zugverwendung bei uns ist die höllentalbahn seit montag
gesperrt sie hat ganze vier wochen funktioniert wieder am arsch aktuell funktioniert das bei
mir tatsächlich ganz okay mit dem zug die skype sounds die skype sounds achso bei ihm
da ja in der in der in dem voice in dem audio ja damals hat man ja auch noch skype verwendet
skype war so 2007 bis 2014 so das ding danach war es discord warst du vom sturm betroffen
ja war ich war ich also nicht von dem der jetzt gerade ist sondern von sabine ich war
von sabine betroffen und zwar weil der zauen im garten bei uns da kann ich jetzt unten
drunter durchlaufen das war der pavlo ich wollte gerade sagen wie hat er den dann erwischt
wenn es fertig ist zähle ich was zum sturm der hat es bisschen bei uns im garten verwüstet
aber ansonsten nichts wildes ja komm jetzt gibt es nuke und gut ist weil ich mein von
der zeit her des videos das ist halt so ein video wo man sagen muss die video die laufzeit
spoilers was passiert das muss jetzt das muss jetzt klappen
der kann ich mal
das gibt den letzten den letzten ffa kill gibt eine nuke oder irgendwie sowas weil viel
kann es nicht mal sein die leute wer ist wir ich habe doch schon
ja ich habe auch ich habe auch gedacht er kriegt jetzt auf den sack
der ist gerade gestorben der hat es rausgeschrieben der hat es rausgeschnitten dass er gestorben
ist oder guck mal wer hat die claymore noch pass mal auf hier
wollte nicht dass man sieht dass er noch gestorben ist oder so ne ne ne ne
ist klar maß äh moin max du hattest ja mal ein video über home office in der it gemacht
ja stimmt äh ich hab nen job der komplett remote ist heißt gar kein büro können wir
gerne mal drüber katschen wenn du willst warum das gibts da so viel zu zu sagen also
ich finde das nicht ich finde das prinzipiell nicht verkehrt vor allem wenn man sowas äh
richtung richtung programmiert also richtung software entwicklung geht wo man halt hauptsächlich
den ganzen tag damit beschäftigt jetzt irgendwelche sachen zu programmieren warum nicht ich
finde das gut und vor allem dass es immer mehr in die richtung geht dass man komplett
komplett remote arbeiten kann da sind wir in deutschland ja ein bisschen hinten dran was
das ganze angeht ähm wenn man sich da jobs anguckt äh beispielsweise in usa da ist das
gang und gäbe dass entwickler komplett remote arbeiten können die suchen ja teilweise auch
entwickler die komplett remote arbeiten da gibts viele firmen die haben gar kein gar
kein gebäude in dem sinn was alle mitarbeiter aufnehmen könnte was das beste an home office
ist dass du weniger für strumpel hinterzahlen musst ja das beste an home office ist eigentlich
dass man nicht morgens auf die arbeit fahren muss und ein bisschen länger pennen kann
und deswegen wache ist äh bei uns gibts da so ein gag äh weil es gibt leute die machen
home office äh offiziell und man hat allerdings halt das gefühl sie machen quasi home minus
offiz also wenn man home minus offiz rechnet bleibt halt nur home übrig und genauso fühlt
sich das bei manchen leuten an wenn die home office machen dass die halt einfach nur home
machen und kein offiz weil sie versuchte teilweise zu erreichen antwortet keiner so äh versuchte
anzuschreiben über skype team sonst was antwortet keiner und du siehst auch abwesen halt irgendwie
seit fünf stunden ähm dann rufst du mal vielleicht irgendwann an so nach dem wort ja ich bin
gerade beim mittagessen dann ist wird irgendwie mal so alibi mäßig ein ticket angeklickt
wo ich echt das gefühl hab dass der macht einfach nur home ohne offiz aber auf der anderen
seite eigentlich ist mir das wurscht ähm ich fände es bloß blöd wenn ich weiß ich hab
halt irgendwas im hals warte mal ich fände es halt nur blöd wenn das zu viele leute
ausnutzen dass man bei uns home office machen kann und halt nichts machen sodass dann irgendjemand
mal auf die idee kommt und zu sagen hey ich weiß nicht home office sollten wir lieber
doch nicht mehr erlauben weil da hab ich keinen bock ich finde das super dass man ab und zu
home office machen kann und ich würde es auch gerne weiter machen deswegen wäre es
ziemlich kacke wenn das manche leute so offensichtlich ausnutzen würden daheim halt zu chillen und
nix zu machen dass man es dann selbst nicht mehr machen darf das wäre doof ich sitze
seit einem jahr im home office arbeite mehr als früher das hab ich auch bei manchen leuten
schon festgestellt dass es ist also es kommt natürlich auf die aber als auch kommt auf
die firma nun es kommt auf die jeweilige person an weil mir ist es auch aufgefallen dass manche
leute da meinung sind dadurch dass sie halt nicht vor ort sind müssten sie jetzt besonders
dann zeigen dass sie was machen und da könnte ich mir vorstellen wenn man so jemand ist dass
das halt dazu führt dass man home office mäßig halt voll überdreibt so vielleicht noch nicht
mal alles aufschreibt knallgas hd muss ich auch sagen ich habe keine ahnung ich muss doch mal
kurz wussten der ff erst mal t einstecken hier excellent asmr plätscher sounds
nicht korona das bestimmt nicht korona das ist ja auch so eine zwischenzeit im twitch chat gewesen
überall wenn irgendwie einer gehustet hat war sofort korona am start knallgas hd ja finde ich
auch also für mich also für mich ist ein riesen vorteil bei der ganzen home office geschichte dass
so diese die bahn geschichte weg fällt zwischendurch also man kann quasi eine stunde länger pen ist
dann auch logischerweise fitter was natürlich auch wichtig ist wenn man wenn man ein bisschen
bisschen ein bisschen nachdenken muss bei dem was man macht und ein ein vorteil der auch nicht zu
unterschätzen ist wenn man wenn man dann seine mail schreibt so nach dem auto home office fertig
für heute dann ist man halt sofort daheim dort hat man home office minus office dann ist er nur
noch home am start flow 690 in der theorie herr schon praktisch gesehen umso größer die firma ist
umso weniger merkt man das also je nachdem umso größer die firma ist und umso umso verzweigt
er das ganze ist umso weniger merkt man das was meinst du warum es bei vielen großen firmen
firmen so viele bullshit shops gibt wo man sich fragt okay für was ist diese position eigentlich
da das war das wissen die leute teilweise selber noch nicht mal richtig also bei uns ist es auch so
wenn man in der richtigen abteil einer richtigen position ist du hättest theoretisch die chance
den ganzen tag nichts zu machen das würde keiner merken problematisch ist halt nur wenn das zu
viele machen würden und man und das irgendwann mal festgestellt wird dann ist halt doof weil
das betrifft dann alle bei uns ist das chinesische zweig der firma geschlossen ja einer der stell
der stellvertreter von meinem chef habe ich gehört er hat sich auch auf corona testen lassen nicht
trotz also sprich wenn die das bei dem festgestellt hätten dann hätten sie bei uns auch dicht gemacht
die sprechen die sysco leute eigentlich corona aus warum
keine ahnung kokona warum sollten die das anders aussprechen ja das das das ist dann
nimmt der trend der trend nimmt zu ich wusste nicht dass in deutschland mittlerweile auch schon
verbreitet ist aber ich weiß dass es in den usa ziemlich verbreitet ist dass es dass es
viele firmen gibt die nur die nur komplett homeoffice machen die haben ja kein gebäude
mehr wo die leute reinpassen
so rona die sysco leute sysco sagen auch sysco das ist eh so eine komische aussprache ich
bin noch für sysco sysco aber es ist ja auch router und nicht router der sysco router
kisco kisco klingt irgendwie wie wie so ein rapper aus dem balkan oder so kisco einer
meiner prof sagt auch immer router ja es ist ich würde fast sagen es ist so 50 50 hatten wir
nicht sogar mal eine abstimmung im chat gemacht ob router oder router und das kam ziemlich
fünf das machen wir jetzt mal leute das müssen wir jetzt mal machen warte mal wobei ich ich
create das glaube ich besser auf dem zweiten bildschirm weil ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
man da nicht irgendwas sieht wo man faken kann enter pool ok ruta ruta oder router
ip duplicate checking gut
create
der titel ist required
aussprache
ok leute also ich poste das jetzt mal im chat und ihr müsst ihr müsst mir jetzt mal sagen
ruta oder router was ist was ist richtig wie spricht was eurer meinung nach aus wir gucken
uns mal live an wie das wie das ganze hier läuft results
mal gucken mal gucken was da rauskommt
ruta ruta liegt ruta führt eindeutiger jetzt rollen eh alle das kann auch sein
ok es ist bei weitem nicht 50 50 es ist eindeutig ruta versus router ruta ruta ruta ruta ruta
hört sich an wie wie eine norwegische öl plattform oder so ruta
ein schwedischer raudersson ok also eindeutig ruta eindeutig ruta router hat verloren also
cisco leute get out
ok was hat er hier für ein video vormarkiert
opened with a fork vault tech live pot ganz safe ah ganz safe ah yes kokona sind wir
sind im wir sind in usa unterwegs eindeutig
wo braucht man sonst einen live pot ganz safe
das ist das ist das ist das ist so only only na problems
er hat keine musik im hintergrund deswegen lassen wir unsere musik einfach weiter laufen
bis sie leise oder bis sie bis sie leise bis sie lauter machen wartet mal ist ein internal
switch
ok ich überlege mir gerade in welcher situation braucht man einen tragbaren waffenschrank
der wasserdicht ist im schwimmbad ja gut bei den amis wird mich das nicht wundern kannst
du dann an die badehose kannst du deine pistole mitnehmen oder was ich frage die ernsthaft
wenn man auf dem schiff ist vielleicht und schiff und hat angst das schiff sinkt und
man muss quasi sein rettungsboot verteidigen gegen die anderen plebs die da rein wollen
keine ahnung ich das ich glaube das sind only kokona things die wir hier sehen
wenn max alles schick ja aktuell schon der chat ist wieder sonderes
da ist ja eine lücke da kriege ich mein finger halb durch das jetzt übertrieben da kann
da also da kann ich ja also mal angenommen ich habe eine brechstange oder so kriege
ich das definitiv auf da muss ich also da muss ich noch nicht mal der lockpicking lawyer
wenn ich da vorne reinkomme mit irgendwas und das ordentlich hebeln kann ist das ding
ist das ding schrott
so i decided to approach the product assuming that switch was engaged and after examination
i discovered i could still open it up that's because the designers made a rookie mistake
they failed to protect adequately the internal button that allows someone to program a new
code and unfortunately all you need to exploit the flaw is a fork i'll show you how that's
done but first let me show you where the button is we need to release these clasps that hold
the plastic lid against the internal gasket then put the default code in 1234 huge code
and we can see the program button and imagine how a fork can be slipped in through the gap
so let's lock this back up oh nice take our fork slip it through the gap now let's try
to atomic sage ich gleich was zu
okay i changed the combination to one one one one moment jetzt habe ich nicht hingeguckt
jetzt habe ich nicht hingeguckt leute jetzt habe ich chat gelesen ich habe nicht hingeguckt
take our fork slip it through the gap now let's try to find that button okay i've changed
the combination to one one one one let's check the old combination you see it does not work
and the new huge security does so while this product does have a few interesting and innovative
features the failure of the designers to adequately protect the reset button is a significant flaw
in any case that's all i have wisst ihr wann sowas rauskommt wenn leute ihre produkte nicht
testen lassen von von leuten die halt wissen was sie tun wie soll das denn wasserdicht
sein wenn er da mit einer gabel reinkommt das ist eine sehr gute frage captain falcon
das ist eine wirklich gute frage also die meinen mit wasserdicht ist wahrscheinlich in dem
fall nicht gemeint dass es quasi unter wasser funktioniert sondern dass einfach wasserabweisend
ist aber trotzdem er ist es halt ist halt ein fehl big brain richtig halt voll für den
arsch wahrscheinlich ist es von aliexpress also das ding ist definitiv nicht ip 65 der
erste der der erste ist staub ne ip also 6 ist staub und 5 ist 5 ist bis zu einem meter
unter wasser ich kann mir das immer nicht gern interessant so um jetzt noch was zu sagen
was tom tricks gefragt hat sauber sagt mal welche netzwerk server monitoring tools nutzt
ihr eigentlich auf der arbeit nachdem mittlerweile nicht mehr alles von einem team gemacht wird
was monitoring angeht ist es ziemlich unterschiedlich also was im netzwerkbereich verwendet wird
kann ich dir gar nicht so genau sagen das macht zum größten teil mittlerweile irgendeine
andere firma keine ahnung server technisch ist eine wilde eine wirklich sehr sehr wilde
mischung aus zabbix elastic surge und kibana und prometreuse krafana haben wir auch noch
und wir haben so ein komisches custom tool eingekauft was sich silk silk performer oder
so irgendwie nennt irgendwie sowas da kann man irgendwelche software clicks automatisieren
ganz ganz krudes old school zeug und wir haben noch ist das dann haben wir noch dings
irgendwie wieso heißt das also unser monitor ist ziemlich er ziemlicher fail muss man das
da haben wir noch haben die haben wir vielleicht auch bilder zu weil es ist eines der hässlichen
der hässlichsten web interfaces ever dieses ding guckt euch das mal an also das sieht
aus wie 1995 also wenn es nach mir geht hätten wir nur zabbix mit prometreuse exporter die
mittlerweile auch im zabbix funktionieren und alles wäre gut wunderbar falls man irgendwelche
dashboard sachen nicht machen könnte könnte man auch ein krafana dabei stellen aber den
ganzen anderen kram ist komplett parallel ingeniertes doppeltes zeug prtg soll aber
wirklich ganz gut sein tom tricks habe ich noch nicht verwendet aber alles was ich bisher
zu gesehen habe und auch empfehlungen von leuten gehört haben von denen ich persönlich
zumindest denke sie wissen wovon sie reden soll das gar nicht so schlecht sein habe ich
ich habe es auch noch nie in den fingern gehabt linux bereich prometheus und krafana ist
nicht schlecht allerdings muss man sich überlegen wofür man das ganze einsetzt prometheus und
krafana ist schön wenn du quasi wie nennen sie das metriken sammelst also quasi statistiken
sammelst so richtig für so reaktionäres monitor mit wie nennt man das reaktionär also sprich
dass es einen alarm gibt und man darauf reagiert finde ich krafana und prometheus in kombination
nicht so schön weil es ist gar nicht so einfach mal in prometheus zum beispiel ein dashboard
also mit prometheus und krafana ein dashboard zu bauen wo man einfach nur drinne sieht ist
der host up oder down das ist gar nicht so einfach es gibt es es hört sich erstmal
einfach an ist es aber gar nicht weil es gibt fünf sechs verschiedene sachen standardmäßig
schon die man checken muss überhaupt dahinter zu kommen ob host up oder down es gibt blackbox
ping check es gibt den den standardmäßigen wie heißt bei wie heißt bei prometheus notes
dass der note antwortet es gibt dann auch die geschichte wenn du beispielsweise auf
den router drauf hast das ist noch mal anders dann hast du dann hast du noch no data received
innerhalb der letzten so und so vielen minuten also einfach nur ein publices dashboard zu
machen mit prometheus und krafana wo drin steht ob host up oder down ist gestaltet sich
komplizierter als man erstmal einen mag wir haben es ja auch mal im stream ausprobiert
und so dafür ist topics halt super für die klassische variante von außen gucken was
sache ist auf dem system vielleicht mit dem agent drauf finde ich ist topics aktuell mit
das beste ein großes problem bei topics ist ich weiß ich ob ich schon mal das web interface
demo gesehen hat ein großes problem von topics ist dass das web interface schlecht ist dass
ich ob die ob die ne demo ob die ne demo haben weil keiner ich glaube die haben keine demo
aber das topics web interface ist wirklich grottenschlecht und auch überhaupt nicht
intuitiv zu bedienen ich mein guckt euch das mal an das ist doch das ist doch lächerlich
man hatte einfach eine webseite genommen und ein riesen formular drauf geklatscht mit allen
optionen das könnte man viel schöner machen und wenn man topics verwendet man wird total
oft mit solchen mit solchen crap hier konfrontiert also sprich wenn man den host aufmacht hat
man hier erst mal das ganze geschiss latest data triggers event craft screens web applications
items triggers craft discovery warum muss das so kompliziert sein mein topics kann
auch unglaublich viel aber das web interface finde ich ist die größte schwäche was was
topics angeht so und dann hatten wir einen chatter sagt er verwendet was ganglia ist
das nicht in den nagios fork war das nicht auch in den nagios fork oder bringe ich das
jetzt durcheinander ne das sieht nicht aus wie nagios fork es gibt es gibt ja im monitor
umfeld so viele nagios es gibt bestimmt 5 6 halbwegs verbreitet nagios forks ist aber
auch nicht mehr dass das e git was ist das für eine will was ist denn das für eine wilde
kombination c pearl php ich wollte gerade sagen phf es sieht aus wie phf c pearl php
und python das ist eine ganz was ist das für eine po das das sieht aus wie eine software
die bei ursprünglich in c entwickelt wurde irgendeiner was mit pearl obendrauf gebastelt
hat dann ein neues web interface in php gebaut wurde und dann neue programmierer an start
gekommen sind die kein bock mehr auf pearl hatten jetzt python machen wollen ganz wilde
ganz ganz wilde measure so ist es auch max das heißt das dachte ich mir so sieht es ja
wirklich aus ja der go live muss nagios ist gut ich mag nagios den ganz klassischen nagios
ich mag den vor allem die config ist ja das was viel wo viel geflammt wird bei nagios
aber ich finde die nagios config hat damals schon die sachen richtig gemacht wenn man
wenn man da einmal durchgeblickt hat ist das gar nicht so wild vor allem kann man die nagios
config wunderbar versionieren also nagios ist nicht schlecht alles aber niemals nagios
doch nagios ist nicht schlecht nagios ist finde ich wenn man wenn man sich mal ein bisschen
mit der config beschäftigt hat beschäftigt hat ziemlich ziemlich simpel findest 30 millionen
plugins also wenn man einfach nur was hinstellen will was jahre gehen soll ohne sich groß drum
zu kümmern ist nagios nicht schlecht aber ich bin wie gesagt so generell würde ich
eher sagen zabbix so das gesamte paket ist zabbix besser aber zabbix ist halt ein riesen
ding was hältst du von ich hinger zinger zwar dass es ja auch in den zabbix fork in
irgendein schwachsinnig zabbix forks nagios fork ich habe mit den ganzen nagios forks
nicht allzu viel gemacht muss ich sagen ich will verwenden auch seit ewig keinen nagios
mehr und ich dachte es als jemand der sich halt mal zwei drei jahre um eine relativ große
nagios installation gekümmert hat den kenne ich mich da auch noch ganz gut aus mit aber
schon ewig her deswegen finde ich es nicht so nicht so schlecht
prometors und influx db da hatten wir es ja gerade von es hat ein bisschen unterschiedliche
anwendungszwecke
prometors und war das prometors db
prometors prometors ist doch so ein eigener die haben doch ein eigenes datenbankformat
ja tom tricks das ist doch fast genau das gleiche ob die jetzt in nagios nimmst oder
in zinger und wenn klar da hat sich zinger ich weiß gar nicht wie man das ausspricht
da hat sich schon viel getan aber man sieht dem ding schon an im kern dass das mal nagios
gewesen ist das hat allein das hier das das ist das schreit alles noch nach nagios plus
das ist ein bisschen moderner ist und man glaube ich mehr übers web interface konfigurieren
kann ich denke auch dass man gucken muss dass man gucken muss was man für was verwendet
prometors und krafana ist super für metriken geschichten und einfach nur abdauen und halt
von außen monitoren und gucken da ist sowas wie zappix und krafana immer noch ganz gut
aber ich finde als gesamtpaket ist mittlerweile zappix unschlagbar weil zappix kann seit
version 4.0 kann das prometors importieren du brauchst quasi du brauchst quasi kein
extra zeug mehr das kannst du kannst quasi aus prometors daten zappix grafen erstellen
das heißt prometors plus zappix ist aktuell so das beste finde ich so das beste monitoren
gesamtpaket was es gibt was mir persönlich ein bisschen fehlt ist was was was mir leid
dass sowas nicht gibt ist dass es keine schöne einfach simple monitoren lösung für daheim
gibt die host verwaltung dhcp dns und und eben monitoren das ist so ein schönes simples
gesamtpaket für daheim sowas sowas fehlt mir noch ein bisschen das was der sache am
nächsten kommt ist tatsächlich wenn man entweder prometors plus krafana nimmt um sich
ein bisschen was zusammenzubauen aber da hast halt auch es ist von heimbereich nicht genau
das was man was man braucht man möchte daheim weniger metriken sammeln eigentlich möchte
man daheim eher wissen der raspberry im keller ist abgeschissen und das geht mit prometors
auch aber ist nicht so schön oder aber oder aber danke für die ganzen subs ich sehe
es ja hier gerade clocks hd sechs monate und dann haben wir noch den moon bear desmond
auch vier monate am start dankeschön progas im stream ink haben wir schon lange nicht
mehr gemacht zumindest die als gesamtpaket finde ich das hier eigentlich am schönsten
aktuell was ich halt cool finden würde wenn es wenn es irgendwie sowas richtig simples
für den heimbereich gebe oder einfach deine host anlegst monitor nee ich habe schon mal
ein bisschen rumgespielt aber das ist wenn so ein großer akt also meine software wisst
ihr doch die wird nie fertig irgendwie guckt euch das das tracker tool an ja da habe ich
monate dran rum gebasteln dann ist kein bock mehr meine software wird nie fertig aus dem
müssen sich den kram anzuporten ja sowas wie abteil robot ist schön oder auch die oder
auch diese geschichten wo du quasi per con job immer wieder aktivierst dass du noch lebst
ist eigentlich ganz nett aber mir fehlt was richtig cool wäre für den heimbereich eine
mischung aus host sprich dort wo ich meine server anlegen kann was es alles gibt was
für mich auch gleich dhcp wusste es nicht unbedingt aber dns wäre cool macht plus einfach
ein paar häkchen für für für einfachste monitoring sachen so nach dem motto dcp port
ist auf host ping platte ist so was ganz so keine ahnung so 15 standard checks und weil
das reicht im heimbereich ja einfach so ein integriertes kleines was alles kann sowas
wäre cool wenn es das für daheim gebe weil mir ist ehrlich gesagt in subx daheim ziemlich
overkill na gut weiter weiter weiter weiter jetzt was haben wir was haben wir sonst noch
für videos heute zu bieten prüte fps masterpiece create per month person how is this even possible
der titel der klingt ja sowas von clickbait da weiß ich mir gar nicht ob ich mir das
angucken soll allerdings hat es viele views und ganz viele und likes und alles deswegen
wirklich gucken wir also sieht ein bisschen aus wie kreises
contain these awesome little fps game is a true masterpiece of its own when you
see it is made by one man studio using the unreal engine unreal ist es nicht nicht
Es ist ein Spiel, in dem man eine große Variante von Fähigkeiten und Abilitäten kombinieren kann, die man durch die Zeit entlocken kann.
So kannst du Dazling-Kombo-Attacken entlocken.
Du kannst Dazling-Kombo-Attacken entlocken.
In der Theorie her ja, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das kaufen würde von einem
Ein-Mann-Laden.
Vor allem wenn das was ist, was mir quasi wo es um Millionenbeträge geht.
Ja gut, das stimmt, das ist aber bei allen Sachen so.
Du brauchst eine gute Idee, das ist ja fast immer so.
Theoretisch, also mal angenommen, man hat ein paar Ideen, das Schwierige ist ja nicht
unbedingt jetzt, also aus seiner Sicht gute Ideen kann man viele haben, was schwierig
abzuschätzen ist, ob die guten Ideen, die man sich so ausdenkt, ob die auch für möglichst
viele anderen auch gute Ideen sind.
Also sprich, nur weil ich mir jetzt was ausgedacht habe, was ich für cool finde heißt es nicht,
dass 50 Millionen Leute auch denken, oh das ist aber was Gutes.
Das heißt, theoretisch könnte man doch sich hinsetzen, ein paar Sachen überlegen und
einfach 15 easy billig Apps rausbringen, in der Hoffnung, dass eine dieser Apps voll
abgeht.
Allerdings, die Chancen sind wahrscheinlich doch relativ gering, wahrscheinlich werden
die meisten Apps keinen Menschen interessieren.
Wir machen einfach Coinmaster.
Moment, warte mal, ich dachte erst, das ist ein Breath of the Wild, I can do it, okay,
das ist es aber gar nicht, sah halt wirklich sehr ähnlich aus.
Ja, an die eindeutig, weil einfach nur im App Store sein bringt dir ja nichts.
Es sind 30 Billiarden Apps im App Store und davon wird kaum eine installiert.
Ja, das gibt es ja im Deutsch auch genug, du musst jetzt nur in diese WhatsApp Gruppe
kommen und wirst Millionär, ist klar, komm in die Gruppe, da bin ich nicht der richtige
für Tutorial Kurse zu machen.
Das ist nicht so einfach, da gibt es ja Konkurrenz, es gibt ja immer von verschiedenen Firmen,
von Google gibt es auch sowas, da können wir uns übrigens mal ein paar Sachen angucken,
das ist tatsächlich ziemlich cool, da gibt es ja diese Capture the Flag Challenges, es
gibt einige, man könnte schon fast sagen, es ist programmiert eSport, allerdings muss
man da halt auch mal ehrlich sagen, die Konkurrenz ist da halt schon ziemlich krass, also da sitzen
keine Noobs, die man da verarschen kann, also ich würde sogar davon ausgehen, bei diesen
Competitions sitzen Leute, die besser sind als du, ich und die meisten der Leute, die
hier so unterwegs sind, so einfach ist das nicht mal neben bei Coding Competition und
Easy Money.
Hört sich nach mee eSport an, als es die OWL ist, ja Overwatch, seit Youtube ist für
mich eh vorbei.
Das war ein Link, Captain Falcon.
Es war kein schlechtes Video, aber es war ziemlich naheliegend, ich meine im Endeffekt
ging es darum, sich was Gutes einzufallen lassen und es dann zu verkaufen, logisch,
ja.
Blizzard, wir müssen reden, Pyne, was erster Eindruck von einem Linux Smartphone, ich glaube
das Ding suckt, Alter, Long Range Sniping Battlefield 3, weiß jemand, Anthem 2.0, oh
das müssen wir jetzt gucken, Anthem 2.0, das wird wahrscheinlich auch wieder, geht
komplett in die Hose, weiß jemand wie die Zuschauerzahlen sind, Youtube, OWL, Vue, Count,
aha, okay, Overwatch League Opening Week on Youtube fails to match Twitch, das war klar,
30.000, ah, das ist schlecht, Alter, ist das schlecht, 30.000, wir hatten ansonsten teilweise
100, 120k und sowas, nur auf Twitch, nicht nice, ja doch, oder je nachdem, wie man sieht,
wenn man sehen möchte, wie Blizzard weiter abkackt, okay, allerdings haben die mit Sicherheit
auch viel Kohle bekommen dafür, dass sie das jetzt exklusiv auf Youtube bringen, 30k
ist schon lächerlich, wie viel hat Montana Black an Zuschauer, ach 30.000 weniger, 30.000
weniger, okay, es sind nur 30.000 weniger, okay, hier, 63.000, 63.000, ja so im Durchschnitt
meine ich jetzt, 63.000, das ist halt, das ist die Hälfte von dem, was sie teilweise
in den Opening Streams gehabt haben auf Twitch, allerdings, muss ich halt sagen, dass, ich
hab's ja auf Twitch schon kaum geguckt, allerdings, jetzt auf Youtube werd ich's mir nicht angucken,
eines der coolsten Sachen war ja, ist ja bei Twitch eh immer der Twitch-Ted dabei, mit
CS muss man's gar nicht als vergleichen, CS war schon immer deutlich größer, was,
Bundesnachrichtendienst, die haben einen GitHub-Repo, allen Ernstes, was gibt's denn da, Bundesnachrichtendienst,
spielst du Overwatch, nein, schon lange nicht mehr, das ist inoffiziell, ah, Bundesnachrichtendienst
Software Reversing Malware Analysis Recruiting Challenge, oder erstmal ein ZIP, Antwortbogen,
ah, wahrscheinlich ist hier das drinnen, was man hierfür zum entschlüsseln braucht,
das können wir uns mal wirklich im Stream angucken, ich geh aber davon aus, dass ich
es wahrscheinlich bei den höheren Levels oder überhaupt voll verkacken werde, mal je nachdem,
was da drinnen ist, mal gucken, wie anspruchsvoll der Bundesnachrichtendienst ist, das können
wir uns echt mal im Stream angucken, ich schreib mir das mal auf, die e-Karriere, ah,
sehr gut, gibt's nicht mehr, lösen sie die Aufgaben, soweit sie dazu in der Lage sind
und legen sie in der ausgefüllten Antwortbogen unserer Stellanze im Erkennziffer, alle für
die Aufgaben notwendig, sowie die Antwortbogen als PDF finden sie im unten verlinkten ZIP-Archiv,
das probieren wir unter Linux dann aus, das merke ich mir, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an,
es ist wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein, ich schau mal, irgendwie eine
Bundestrojaner am Start, Anthem 2.0, der Maurice wieder, die sind ja mit ihrem eigenen, mit
ihrem eigenen Update-Programm maßlos hinterher, wie viele Leute hat die GameStar eigentlich,
ich guck mir öfters Videos von der GameStar an, aber außer so 3, 4 Leute sitzen da immer
andere, ich kenn die alle gar nicht, hallo, wir sind beide so ein bisschen Anthem-Geschädigte,
wir haben das zum Release viel gespielt, durchaus, bisschen leise oder, soll ich noch ein bisschen
lauter machen, oder passt das so, vorsichtiger Hoffnung, es ist ja immerhin noch BioWare
gewesen, trotz gewisser negativer Vorzeichen, erzähl doch mal ein wenig, du hast das sogar
noch länger gespielt als ich, BioWare ist für mich schon seit ein paar Jahren vorbei,
das letzte gute Spiel, was BioWare rausgebracht hat, war Dragon Age 1, oder mal gucken, ich
muss mal kurz gucken, was die noch alles rausgebracht haben, nicht dass ich Mist erzähle, aber irgendwie
eine ordentliche Übersicht über BioWare Games, List of BioWare Video Games, okay, also was
haben wir denn da alles Schönes, Sucked, Sucked, ah, gecancelt, Sucked, war ganz okay, hab ich
nicht gespielt, soll ganz okay gewesen sein, aber war weitem nicht das, was man sich da
erhofft hatte, ist gecancelt, keine Ahnung, Sucked, also Mass Effect hat mir das eins
auch ganz gut gefallen, der Rest war echt nicht meins, mittlerweile soll es ja ganz okay
sein, weil sie neue Enten nachgereicht haben und sowas, aber, okay, ich glaube wir fangen
mal von der anderen Richtung an, eines der besten Games ever, ich hab keine Ahnung was
das ist, auch richtig gut, war nicht mein Fall, muss ich sagen, war damals auch übelst
nice, sagt mir nix mehr großartig, richtig gut, Moment, die haben ein Sonic Game gemacht,
ernsthaft, Dragon Age, auch extrem gut, das war, ich muss euch sagen, ich glaube das hier
war das letzte richtig gute BioWare Game, da waren sie erst ganz frisch bei EA und EA
hatte noch nicht mehr so viel Einfluss da drauf, auf das Game, die kamen quasi erst
am Ende dazu und alles was danach kam ist für ein Arsch, okay, Dragon Age 1 war finde
ich echt nicht schlecht, es ist nicht gut gealtert, die Grafik sieht heute ein bisschen
kacke aus, ich hab es letztens erst wieder gesehen bei Dance Gaming auf Twitch, es sieht
halt schon ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen aus, also nach EA war es vorbei, könnte man
so sagen, was in Dragon Age halt richtig cool war, dass du das Gefühl hattest, dass deine
Party halt gelebt hat, so in Anführungsstrichen, die hatten coole Dialoge, die hatten Interaktion
und alles drum herum, das war halt sehr, sehr nice und hier haben wir mal das schöne aus
etwas älteren Rollenspielen, weniger Rüstung gleich mehr Rüstung.
Ich glaube, das war auch das Einzige bei Anthem, was was getaugt hat, ich habe es von Anfang
an gesagt, dass Anthem der absolute Rockkrepierer wird, weil das Spiel von Anfang an so retortenmäßig
ausgesehen hat, ein bisschen davon, ein bisschen davon und eigentlich weiß man nicht so genau,
was es sein sollte und jetzt hat sich herausgestellt, intern war das genau das gleiche, genauso
wie es gewirkt hatte, man hat zwar coole Trailer gemacht, aber im Prinzip hatten sie intern
auch keine Ahnung, was sie eigentlich machen wollten und genauso hat es auch gewirkt.
Was dann immer mehr mit der Zeit, immer mehr dann auch in meinem Bewusstsein gekrochen ist,
alles andere ist halt einfach nicht gut, das Schießen macht keinen Spaß, die Loot.
Wenn ich sowas schon sehe, dieses krampfhafte Reinprügeln von irgendwelchen Roleplay Mechanics,
die die Spiele überhaupt nicht brauchen, die aber dazu führen, dass man halt schöne
easy Content Updates liefern kann, dass die Leute das möglichst lange spielen, plus halt
noch schöne Microchance Actions und schöne DLC Geschichten und Content und Abos und sonst
was verkaufen kann, das schadet den Games mehr, als das ihnen bringt.
Man kann überhaupt keine Abwechslung, total lahme Waffen, alles einfach nur irgendwelche
Sturmgewehre, Shotguns, nichts besonderes und naja gut, die Story war dann auch eher so
sehr... Eigentlich ist es ja mal eines der Sachen, die sowohl BioWare mal gut konnte
storymäßig, Blizzard hatte das auch gut drauf.
Was man von BioWare erwartet jedenfalls. Und auch nicht was versprochen wurde, da wurde
wirklich eine Revolution... Xeroxino, ja es wird mal wieder Zeit, aber Bahn funktioniert
in letzter Zeit tatsächlich ganz gut, so gut wie es funktionieren kann. Danke schön für
den Sub.
Das hat mich so ein bisschen verbittert, weil ich finde was BioWare, was EA beworben hat,
ist das nicht glücklich geblieben, also man hat uns da das nächste Forever Game versprochen
und das Spiel...
Den Bob Dylan der Videospiele, das ist immer noch großartig.
Fantastisches Zitat und...
Ich finde das sogar, das haben die ja wirklich gesagt, Bob Dylan der Videospiele, so geil,
das ist so... Da sieht man mal, dass Marketing Bullshit in keinem Verhältnis zu dem eigentlichen
Produkt stehen muss.
Man hat gesagt, ja Spiel, das wird euch für tausend Stunden beschäftigen, am Ende für
viele Leute war es glaube ich nicht mehr als fünf Stunden, weil es sich halt einfach super
schnell ausgeplant ist, weil es ist nichts mehr gekommen.
Bist du an die Quest mit den Grabmailern gekommen, das glaube ich, da sind schon viele ausgestiegen,
die haben dann auch ein bisschen gepatcht, aber trotzdem...
Okay, keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen, was war die Quest mit den Grabmailern, war
das eben so eine 500 Stunden Grind-Quest, um zu verstecken, dass man keinen Content mehr
hatte oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Hast du aber trotzdem ihm noch mal eine Chance gegeben, es hat ja dann BioWare eine Weile
lang versucht, sag ich mal mit eher kleineren, additiven Inhaltsupdates das Spiel wieder
auf Kurs zu bringen, sie haben auch manche Sachen durchaus sinnvoll gepatcht, also es
ist so ein bisschen komfortabler geworden, jeder Patch hat auch wieder Probleme mit sich
gebracht, zweimal haben sie zum Beispiel die Loot-Schraube versehentlich nach oben gedreht
und haben es dann wieder korrigiert, obwohl die Fans sie angefleht haben, macht das nicht,
aber das waren alles keine Revolutionen und dann kam endlich mit viel Verspätung dieses
große Inhaltsupdate der Cataclysm, da hast du reingeschaut, hat dich aber auch nicht
lange gehalten.
Richtig, genau, ich habe da bei den Cataclysm noch mal reingeschaut, war ganz nett, aber
mehr halt auch nicht, also es kamen dann zum Beispiel endlich mal ein paar Waffen, die
ein bisschen more exciting waren.
Eins muss man sagen, technisch gut gemacht, sieht es ja schon aus, also wie sagt man so
schön, production value, also das sieht schon aus, als haben da keine Noobs dran gearbeitet,
aber vom Inhalt her ist es halt für den Arsch.
Irgendwelche ballistischen Schusswaffen, sondern auch was mit irgendwelchen Blitzen und irgendwas,
was dann so Klingen verschossen hat, war alles ganz cool, aber das Event an sich hat
halt, es hat halt an dem eigentlichen Problem, was Anthem hat, nichts geändert.
Nämlich, dass die Gameplay Loop, die macht einfach keinen Spaß.
Und jetzt haben sie ja tatsächlich endlich gesagt, dass sie wirklich größer rangehen
wollen.
Interessanterweise auch, was erstmal bedeutet, das Spiel wird jetzt auch erstmal weiter
tote Hose haben, also sie haben damit auch gesagt, das kann ich in dem Fall sogar nachdrücken.
Die haben ja ihren eigenen Contentplan nicht eingehalten.
Sowas passiert, wenn man Programmierern keine Vorgabe gibt, naja eher umgedreht.
Wenn du keinen Plan hast, was gemacht werden soll, das ist ja nicht die Schuld der Leute,
die das ganze programmieren.
Oder ja, doch, könnte man schon so sehen, aber ich meine, es ist ja nicht die Aufgabe
der Leute, die die Sache entwickeln, das große und ganze sich vorher zu überlegen,
dass das was zusammenhängendes rauskommt.
Also vor allem, wenn du halt morgen das machen sollst und heute das.
Wir sagen, wir machen jetzt keine weiteren Seasons oder sowas, wir konzentrieren uns
jetzt voll darauf, das Spiel wirklich in ihren eigenen Worten neu zu erfinden.
Da muss ich ganz gut einhaken, da wäre es vielleicht aber tatsächlich der beste Move
gewesen, von EA so eine Schiene zu fahren.
Kanalpunkte, ja zum Thema Kanalpunkte kann ich nur sagen, ich habe es mir doch nicht
wirklich angeguckt.
Ich habe das Default Zeug drinne, also richtig Loopstyle.
Ja, bei Final Fantasy XIV hat sich das gelohnt, Final Fantasy XIV ist jetzt ganz gut geworden.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, ob sie es trotzdem hinkriegen, ich fand ja ganz interessant, die interessanteste
Aussage fand ich eigentlich, dass sie gesagt haben, diesmal werden wir das tun, wovon wir
beim ersten Mal schon gerne mehr gemacht hätten, nämlich einem fokussierten Team wirklich Zeit
geben zu iterieren und zu testen, das ist eine Aussage, die hätte finde ich viel früher
kommen sollen.
Ja gut, aber das Game hat Geld gekostet, das muss raus und ein bisschen Kohle.
Anthem 2, nee das ist Season 2, das ist ein Update, klein, klein, klein.
Max darf ich fragen, wo du deine Domain her hast, hier, da habe ich die her, gibt aber
viele günstige Domain-Auster, das ist der billigste, den ich damals in meiner Suche
gefunden habe.
Das Problem bei denen ist, dass der DNS keine API hat, das heißt sprich, wenn man letzte
Krypt-Zertifikate über DNS-Challenge machen will, dann geht das nicht richtig, deswegen
habe ich mein DNS jetzt auf Cloudflare laufen.
Noch so PR-Statements, das wird schon alles irgendwie wieder und mit dem Cataclysm werden
wir euch endlich zeigen, wozu Anthem alles in der Lage ist und so, nee, war nicht so.
Ja, hat auch gesagt.
Aber trotzdem.
Fällt euch mal auf, man sieht eigentlich nur immer sinnlos Leute rumfliegen, weil das
wohl die einzige Mechanik ist, die irgendwie Spaß macht, das ist für'n Arsch.
Nicht schlecht.
Achso und übrigens noch was Leute, wenn ihr euch Domains kauft, auch wenn man das offiziell
in allen Vorschritten nicht darf, man kann sich da ohne Probleme mit Fake-Namen registrieren,
weil die ganzen Domain-Registrare haben überhaupt kein Interesse dran, euch zu bannen wegen
Fake-Namen oder das überhaupt nur rauszukriegen, weil dann bezahlt ihr ja kein Geld mehr.
Das heißt, registriert euch einfach mit Fake-Namen, dann braucht ihr kein Geld für Whois-Protection
bezahlen.
Wird das jetzt wirklich mal solche Aussagen ein bisschen kommen, finde ich?
Ja, aber bisher würde ich sagen too little, too late.
Ja, also da muss man ganz klar sagen, Taten zählen, also das werden sie jetzt beweisen
müssen.
Sie haben gesagt, in den nächsten Monaten werden sie daran arbeiten, das könnte also
sogar noch ein Release 2020 bedeuten, haben sie nicht auch gesagt?
Die müssen ja, die müssen ja, das Game ist dead.
Also wenn die das irgendwie noch retten wollen, können sie dann in sich fünf Jahre Zeit lassen.
Aber kommen wir doch mal ein bisschen dahin, was sie ändern wollen und was sie ändern
sollten.
Und sie haben ja schon, glaube ich, recht gut gesagt, was so das Hauptfeedback war,
dass es zu wenig Progression, zu wenig geile Beute und zu wenig gutes Endgame gab, würdest
du zustimmen, dass das auch genau die Kritikpunkte sind?
Auf jeden Fall.
Und sie sprechen ja auch, glaube ich, später auch noch mal im Statement die Core Gameplay
Loop an.
Und genau, ich finde, das ist da, wo sie wirklich ran müssen.
Dem Spiel fehlt es jetzt, wie gesagt, ich habe es nicht selbst gespielt, nur von allem,
dem was ich gesehen habe, das ist einfach nur drum herum gedoktere.
Dem Spiel fehlt es einfach an Seele, dem Spiel fehlt es an Identität und dem Spiel fehlt
es einfach an das, was es irgendwie herausstechen lässt.
Das wirkt einfach wie lieblos zusammengeschustert und das wird man auch mit mehr Endgame nicht
großartig retten können.
Hey Max, leider ein bisschen off-topic, aber hast du ein Tipp, wie man am besten mit Python
anfängt?
Ja, vor allem erstmal anfangen und dann musst du dir überlegen, was du machen willst.
Willst du Web-Anwendungen machen?
Was willst du machen?
Also was ist der Grund überhaupt, warum du mit Python anfangen willst?
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn Anthem 2.0 wirklich ein schönes Spiel wird, aber die haben da
echt eine Menge Arbeit vor sich, also da gibt es ganz viel zu tun, damit die Leute wieder
ins Boot bekommen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es hinkriegen, so wie bei Rainbow Six, was ja am Anfang auch
nicht so wahnsinnig angesagt war oder Battlefield 4 oder was, es gab es ja noch für Beispiele.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Genauso wie ich nicht glaube, dass Stadia noch die Kurve kriegt.
Real Aiyoki, Twitch Prime, zwei Monate, huge Prime-Sub, ach so geht das.
Ja, jetzt wo du weißt, wie es geht, ist ja easy für die nächsten Monate, ne?
Borderlands ist ein gutes Beispiel, wo die sich was abgucken könnten.
Und selbst Borderlands 3, finde ich, hätte einiges gehabt, was man auch verbessern könnte.
Vor allem die Main-Quest war nicht so gut.
Ich will Blaster, ich will Phaser, all das, was man eben so aus solchen Settings kennt,
das wäre für mich eigentlich das Hauptding, wenn die Beute so abgedreht wäre, wie es
in Borderlands 3 zum Beispiel ist, wäre es dann so viel besser.
Letztens, habt ihr es gesehen, haben die die Division 2, was ist das, Addon oder DLC oder
sowas, haben die ja letztens vorgestellt und da haben sie ein paar Streamer bezahlt, unter
anderem bei Dance Gaming war das zu sehen, bei Seagull war das zu sehen und ihr hättet
den Chat sehen müssen, Leute, wie der Chat über das Game hergezogen hat und ich muss
euch halt sagen, der Twitch-Chat, der übertreibt gerne, aber in dem Fall hatte der Twitch-Chat
einfach recht.
Außer meinen Twitch-Chat, der hat natürlich immer recht, aber, äh ja, ne, auch nicht,
auch nicht.
Der legt öfters mal richtig, ja, aber der Twitch-Chat hatte tatsächlich komplett
recht, was das angegangen ist, was die letzte Division 2 Erweiterung anbelangt hat.
Es sah halt einfach ultra langweilig aus.
Boah, der ist aus dem Steg greiflich.
Destiny, von Borderlands, von Warframe, von den ganzen anderen Spielen, die es einfach
besser machen und coole Waffen, coole Loot und auch die Fähigkeiten finde ich, das war
auch alles ziemlich lahm.
Was glaubst du denn, was man machen könnte?
Zu 0815 halt, das ganze Game sah von Anfang an einfach zu generic, zu zusammengeschustert
aus.
Emoji please, Emotes please, ja, kommt alles noch, kommt alles noch.
Das Endgame zu retten, auszubauen, die langfristige Progression auch.
Ja, klar, irgendwie was in die Richtung von einem Raid, wäre ganz cool, vielleicht irgendwas,
ich glaube, vier Spieler sind glaube ich die Strongholds.
Ich glaube vier, es gab auch nicht viele Strongholds, es gibt keine Raids oder kein
ordentlicher Group Endgame Content in Anthem.
Irgendwas mit coolen Mechaniken, was wirklich Teamplay voraussetzt, irgendwas, wo du auch
wirklich deine gute Gier dann auch gebrauchen kannst.
Ja, es gab ja auch wirklich sehr wenige.
Ja Michael, dauert nicht mal lang, fünf Jahre oder so, kann man von drüber, oder?
Doch, ich mache das, ich kümmere mich um die Emotes, es wird echt mal Zeit, ich habe
irgendwie noch 22 Emote Slots oder so, noch übrig.
Auch sehr hilfreich wäre, wären vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Events oder Ereignisse,
die ein bisschen mehr Zufallsfaktor auch noch haben, also mehr Wiederspielwert, zum Beispiel
Leute rennen immer noch gern durch Nephalim Portale in Diablo 3 oder erst recht in Path
of Exile die Maps, die halt immer komplett Zufalls generiert sind.
Beste, beste Leute, beste.
Path of Exile, ich meine, ich will nicht von einer ganz so Free-To-Play-Geschichte anfangen,
ich finde es trotzdem immer noch ein echt faires Modell, aber Path of Exile macht das
Endgame technisch extrem gut, der Übergang von Story Ende zu Endgame habe ich selten
so weich und so suchtfördernd gesehen, wie sie das in Path of Exile hingekriegt haben,
das haben die wirklich gut gemacht.
Du beendest die Story und dein Charakter ist ganz okay, ich meine, du musst ja in der
Story nicht großartig was machen und du kannst direkt mit dem Story-Charakter nach ein paar
sinnlosen Miniquests kannst du direkt anfangen mit Endgame-Content und es gibt auch nicht
wenig.
Erstmal minus 60 Resis, Story ist Easy Mode, Story ist nicht, das kriegt man dann ganz
gut hin.
Du kannst dann immer noch, du kannst direkt anfangen, irgendwie Tier 1-2 Maps zu machen
und ein bisschen vor dich hinzukreinen, du hast wahrscheinlich auch schon ganz gut
Währung, kannst dir ein bisschen ordentliches Equipment kaufen, also der Übergang, das führt
dich in Path of Exile wirklich richtig gut da an die ganze Sache ran.
Aus Versatzstücken leichter zusammenbauen, aber so diese zufälligen Missionen, das Problem
ist glaube ich bei Anthem eher auch, es gab ja so diese Missionen, die man dann machen
konnte, die so ein bisschen immer so zufällig zusammen gestrungen wurden, da haben wir aber
die, es gab nicht genügend Versatzstücke, war find ich mein Problem, also es gab nicht
genügend Gegnertypen, nicht genügend Umgebung, nicht genügend Missionsziele, nicht genügend
Mechaniken.
Herz 93, naja Maps ist so die Hauptmechanik, allerdings gibt es sehr viele Maps, es gibt
den, du musst halt deinen ganzen Atlas ausbauen, dann gibt es noch ein paar Bosskämpfe, was
du quasi nach und nach freischalten musst, dann gibt es noch stärkere Varianten von den
Bosskämpfen, dann gibt es noch ein paar Tempel, dann gibt es noch das Lab, dann gibt es, es
gibt relativ viele Sachen, also es ist nicht nur Maps-Spam eins nach dem anderen, allerdings
ist das eines der Sachen, die man halt viel macht, Maps-Spammen, aber es gibt, es wird
nicht langweilig, das wichtigste, was man im Pass of Exile Endgame braucht, ist allerdings
ein ordentlicher Loot-Filter, weil ansonsten explodiert das Gehirn, ohne ordentlichen Loot-Filter,
und was halt richtig Spaß macht im Pass of Exile ist, dadurch, dass du halt 16 Schwierigkeitsstufen
von den ganzen Maps hast, ne, es ist nicht nur, es ist nicht nur Maps laufen, aber es
ist relativ viel Maps laufen, dadurch, dass du halt die verschiedenen Schwierigkeitsstufen
mit den Maps hast, aber dadurch, dass du Maps machst, anlockst du automatisch schon quasi
neue Progression, du musst erstmal die ganzen Watchdowns anlocken, die du dann, die kannst
du dann im Atlas einsetzen und dann verschiedene Upgrades damit auch noch spendieren, dann
kannst du die Boss-Fights machen, dann kannst du jetzt, den allerletzten Boss-Fights hab
ich auch noch nicht gemacht, ja, diesen Awakener-Dings, Gedöns, keine Ahnung, ich spiel, also ich
spiel zwar viel Pass of Exile, aber ich bin Noob, ja, also ich hab bei weitem auch keinen,
keinen wirklich da großen Plan von, ähm, zumal ich auch ein absolutes Noob-Bild spiele,
das heißt ich kann, mit übelsten Crap Gear kann ich T12, T13 Maps machen, ähm, ohne
zu sterben, ich spiel halt Summoner mit, äh, also Physical Damage Skelette Summoner, das
ist halt das größte Noob-Bild, was du in diesem Spiel machen kannst, das ist für
den letzten Crack-Noob, ja, du gehst hin, drückst den Knopf und wenn du, und wenn du Angst hast
zu sterben, drückst du deine Skelette einfach nur in die Nähe vom Gegner und bleibst offscreen
während deiner Skelette alles killen, du machst einfach nur Armor an, buffst die noch, das
ist wirklich, du kannst eigentlich nichts falsch machen mit diesem Build, ja, ich hab
zwei, ich hab zwei Sachen gespielt dieses Season, ich hab, äh, angefangen mit diesem
Arc-Witch-Guide, wir machen jetzt einfach ein bisschen Pass of Exile, so, das womit
war, glaub ich, jeder angefangen hat in diesem Game, äh, hab ich mit diesem Guide angefangen,
damit hat jeder mal angefangen, ja, so, und da hab ich die Story durchgespielt und hab,
ähm, bisschen Maps gemacht und hatte auch Glück, dass mir, äh, irgendwie gleich bei
der zweiten Map, so, die Level, die Level-Chest schlechthin getroppt ist, zweimal, zweimal
Level-Chest schlechthin getroppt ist, äh, hallo, warum zeigt das keine, keine Sockel
an, das Ding, und da hab ich mir gedacht, ok, wenn ich jetzt schon so eine gute Level-Chest
habe, mach ich mir einfach noch einen Summoner und, äh, hab dann innerhalb von einem Tag
oder so meinen Summoner durch, Story durchgespielt und Endgame gefarmt, quasi besser als ich
mit dem anderen Charakter konnte, weil's halt so ein absolutes Noob-Bild ist, das Ding
spiel ich ja aktuell, so, das, das ist der Build, den ich aktuell spiel, und das ist
wirklich absoluter Noob-Bild, das kann jeder spielen, du brauchst nichts an Gear, im Endeffekt,
zum, zum, zum Einstieg, ja, du brauchst nichts an Gear, und du kannst alles clearen, es ist,
es ist eigentlich schon zu OP, das Ding, wenn man sich anguckt, was er hier, was er hier
Sample Gear vorschlägt, ähm, das ist, das ist nichts, das, das kriegst du, das kriegst
du fast schon beim Leveln zusammen, was der Typ hier hat, es ist wirklich easy, ähm,
das einzige, was ich mir noch gekauft habe, also das einzige, was ich bisher getradet hab,
in der ganzen League, also sprich, würde ich mehr traden, könnte ich auch einen deutlich
besseren Charakter schon haben, aber ich verzichte erstmal drauf, weil ich gucken will, was
es alles an Game-Inhalten gibt, ja, das einzige, was ich mir getradet hab, für den Charakter
ist ein, ja, ist, ist ein Level 20, Quality 20 Skill-Game, dafür, für 20 Chaos Orbs
oder so, und was ich auch jedem empfehlen kann, der Path of Exile Endgame macht, ist, ähm,
ist das Tool, bzw. die neue Version, das trackt den Progress, den man, ähm, an, an, an Ingame-Währungen
macht, also sprich, man, äh, startet das Tool, meldet sich an und, ähm, sagt, welche,
welche Stash-Taps, bzw. welche, welche, dort, dort, wo man seine Items und, und Gegenstände
aufbewahrt, das Ding überwachen soll, denn, ähm, man hat oftmals das Gefühl, wenn man
quasi Endgame-Grinding macht in Path of Exile, also nach dem Motto, es geht, es geht nicht
vorwärts irgendwie, ja, es wäre, äh, man verliert quasi mehr, mehr als man einsetzt,
und wenn man, wenn man das Ding hier als Tracker anhat, sieht man, dass man nach einem Tag,
äh, Maps-Grinden einfach mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, tausend, also übertrieben, ja, wobei,
ja, doch, komm, kommt, kommt doch hin, je nachdem, wie viel man, wie viel man grindet, keine
Ahnung, 500 plus, äh, Chaos Orbs an, an Value gemacht hat, äh, einfach durch permanentes
Spielen, ohne den krassen High-End-Content machen zu müssen, ähm, einfach, einfach
durch Spielen, und das ist halt, äh, auch ein großer Motivator, weil wir wissen ja,
Stonks, wir mögen, wir mögen alles grafen, was nach oben geht, und das ist wirklich sehr
praktisch das Tool, auch wenn es manchmal nicht ganz stimmt, was es ausgibt, so, gucken
wir mal weiter, äh, Wulffy69, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Sub, IAQ Sub, Dankeschön, Wulffy69,
Sub, Doppelpack-Abo heute, ja, Dankeschön, ihr beiden, so, ähm, gucken wir mal das Video
weiter.
Hast du da wirklich viel abwechseln, also, ich mein, das hat jetzt tatsächlich, die
Nephalin-Portale, die haben auch nicht abwechseln, soll ich mich halten.
Diablo 3 ist für mich komplett dead, ne, also Diablo 3 hab ich seit einem Jahr oder zwei
Jahren oder so nicht mal angefasst, ich hab mal noch ein bisschen gespielt, wo die umgestellt
haben auf komplett self-found, aber mittlerweile, nope, aber Diablo 3 hat immerhin zum Beispiel
sehr abwechslreiche Umgebungen und Feindestypen, die du da alle reinwerfen kannst, Anthem hat
es ja gar nicht.
Ja, ich finde auch, die Gegner waren total austauschbar, alle, da war keine große Dynamik
auf beiden Seiten.
Das ist auch was, was Path of Exile, finde ich, ziemlich gut hinkriegt, ähm, wenige,
also die meisten Action-RPGs haben es geschafft bei mir, dass mir die paar Gegnertypen, die
es gibt, schon nach, ähm, keine Ahnung, nach zwei mal durchspielen so auf den Sack
gehen, dass man die Gegnertypen gar nicht mehr sehen kann.
In Path of Exile gibt es erstens relativ viele verschiedene Gegnertypen, aber es ist auch
endlich, ja, es ist kein allzu riesen Pool, aber das Schöne an Path of Exile, finde ich,
ist, dass die, dass der, die Geschwindigkeit vom Gameplay so hoch ist, dass es eigentlich
fast egal ist, was man für Gegner, äh, weggacken slayed, man, man nimmt das kaum noch zur
Kenntnis, ob man da jetzt irgendwelche, ähm, Dämonen killt oder irgendwelche Tiere killt
oder irgendwelche Geister wegbashed, da ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Unterschied, einfach
alles weg, äh, wegstellen und Loot abgreifen.
Super agile Javelin, der, der super coole Flugmanöver machen konnte, aber es war egal,
weil die Gegner haben sich eh nicht bewegt, im Prinzip, du bist ein bisschen gestrafend,
hast geschossen und auf was du dann geschossen hast, war dann egal, und das gleiche ist auch
die Umgebung.
Der Termin ist halt voll für den Arsch, äh, was, was die, was die, was die Overworld angeht
und that's it, da war irgendwie nicht ne Wüstenlandschaft, ne Eislandschaft, die, die, die Klassiker
halt, ja, Eis, Feuer, Wüste, Regenwald, Wüste, allein, wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn sie diese
drei Biome schon irgendwie in diese Welt integriert hätten, das wär schon mal ein großer Zugewinn
gewesen, aber nein, es war überall nur, ich mein, man sieht, dass technisch das Spiel
echt gut ist, ich mein, guckt euch das mal an, das haben keine Noobs gebastelt, dass
ist technisch schon nicht schlecht, das Problem ist halt, dass dem Spiel komplett die Seele
und, und die Identität fehlt.
Irgendwie nicht ne Wüstenlandschaft, ne Eislandschaft, die, die, die Klassiker halt, ja, Eis, Feuer,
äh, Regenwald, allein, wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn sie diese drei Biome schon irgendwie
in diese Welt integriert hätten, das wär schon mal ein großer Zugewinn gewesen, aber
nein, es war überall nur grün.
Ja, halten wir also fest, wir würden uns erwarten bessere und vielfältigere Loot,
was Waffen und Fähigkeiten angeht, mehr Abwechslung im Endgame, Abwechslung, Abwechslung ist glaub
ich der Punkt schlechthin, wo man sagen kann, Endgame braucht mehr Abwechslung, mehr Tiefe
und mehr Abwechslung.
Genau, also abwechslungsreicher Aktivitäten im Endgame und auch eben abwechslungsreichere,
abwechslungsreichere Umwelt in Sachen Welt und Gegner.
Jetzt muss man halt aber, finde ich, schon sagen, es gibt ein Pub, also zum Beispiel
abwechslungsreichere Loot, ist jetzt, ich sag mal, leicht ist das falsche Wort, aber
ist machbar, da brauchst du glaub ich auch gar nicht so viel Personal dafür, um ein
paar coole Waffen zu codeen, ein paar Effekte dazu zu basteln, auch Gegnertypen würde ich
sagen, kannst du auch, sag ich mal, du brauchst keine volle Entwicklermannschaft überhaupt
mehr, um neue Gegnertypen zu basteln und du brauchst ja auch gar nicht so unglaublich
viele, wenn du ein paar hast, die cool sind, die ein bisschen vielfältig sind, die du
dann so mix and matchen kannst in Zufallsevents, schwieriger sehe ich halt so die ganze Sache
mit Welt und auch Aktivitäten, weil da müsstest du ja wirklich viel dazu basteln, vor allem
du brauchst halt auch, das ist halt auch eines der, nennen wir das mal in Anführung schrieb,
Probleme, wenn du so ein AAA Production Value Monster hast, sprich, wo an jeder Ecke halt
was drinstecken, was gemacht werden muss, du kannst nicht einfach mal irgendwie großartig
Content mit ein paar Mann einbauen, das Zeug muss ordentlich geschrieben sein, du brauchst
Synchronsprecher, du brauchst Leute, die dir das animieren, du brauchst Zeug, die dir
das machen, also das ist nicht mal einfach gemacht, wie in irgendwie einem Ein-Mann-2D-Projekt,
so nach dem Motto, ah ich hab jetzt eine neue Map erstellt, ein bisschen Text und eine Quest
ist fertig, da steckt halt schon ein bisschen mehr dahinter und das jetzt mal so quasi
raus aus dem Ärmel schütteln, eh nicht und die Frage ist halt, wieviel die auch noch
bereit sind an Geld da rein zu investieren in ein Game, was halt so abgekackt ist?
Und ich fand tatsächlich auch immer, das war für mich eines der größten Probleme
von Anthem, wie es dieses Kernversprechen, die ganze Story war ja auch darauf ausgelegt,
eine Welt, in der alles passieren kann, die sich ständig ändert, und dann hast du eigentlich
nach zwei Stunden auch alles gesehen, auch jeden Missionstyp, jeden Gegnertypen, da
konnte überhaupt nicht alles passieren, ich hab selten eine Suchformulierung.
Es gab doch vor einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren, war ein neues MMO, total gehyped, wo die Entwickler
auch wieder behauptet haben, so nach dem Motto, die komplette Welt lebt und hier Events und
nie werden Spielgebiete obsolet und player-driven Events und alles mögliche, wo ich damals
schon gesagt hab, jaja, das erzählen sie alle und am Ende ist es halt, ohne weiteres gar
nicht, nein, kein BDO, kein Destiny, kein No Man's Sky, irgendein MMO war das, wo ich
auch schon damals gesagt hab, so ein Blödsinn, das erzählen hier alle, kriegt es aber nicht
hin, weil da auch so handfeste Gameplay-Sachen im Weg stehen, Blesson, das, nee, nee, nee,
Bless war das nicht, Bless war dieser Asia-Rockgrip, nee, nee, nee, irgendwas anderem, irgendwas
anderem.
Ich weiß nicht, was das war.
Es ist ja auch schwierig, Gebiete in einem MMO zu bauen, die quasi für alle Level relevant
sind.
Das ist nicht einfach, wie willst du das machen, Gescheit?
Es könnte Crowfall, es könnte vielleicht Crowfall gewesen sein, ja.
Und viele MMOs haben es auch schon probiert mit Welten, die quasi sich permanent ändern,
es gibt halt Sachen in MMOs, die beißen sich.
Will ich eine Story erzählen, ist eine Welt, die sich auf Spieleraktion ändert, also eine
persistente Welt, die für alle gleich ist, die sich auf Spieleraktion ändert, in Kombination
mit Story.
Geht halt nicht, wenn die Welt zu einem gewissen Story-Zeitpunkt in einem gewissen Zustand
sein will, dann kann ich keine persistente Welt für alle spielen, das funktioniert so
nicht.
Da muss ich anfangen mit solchen Geschichten, wie, dass ich nur Spieler sehen kann, mit
gleichem Level oder beziehungsweise zumindest mal gleicher Story-Progression.
Und das ist halt nicht, was für mich quasi irgendwie MMOs richtig ausmachen.
Mir fehlen eh die großen MMO-Releases, so zur Zeit, wo vor WoW nach WoW, da kam ja quasi
jede Woche ein neues MMO raus und jedes MMO war der WoW-Killer und jedes MMO war besser
und sonst was, die meisten waren halt crap, aber es waren auch ein paar ganz gute bei.
Es gibt keine guten MMO-Releases mehr.
Auf das Amazon-MMO bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt, dadurch, dass es eben ein bisschen
weniger Story-fokussiert und Kampagnen-fokussiert sein wird, sondern mehr Sandbox und mehr Player-zentriert
sein wird.
Ja, selbst Elder Scrolls Online ist ja, weiß nicht, es hat sich wohl viel zum besseren
MMO geändert, aber Elder Scrolls Online ist ja wohl auch so ein Hybrid aus, wir versuchen
ein bisschen die PvP-Leute anzusprechen, aber das, wobei ich weiß nicht, wie es aktuell
ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das PvP-Gebiet hat zumindest am Anfang ziemlich gefällt
in Elder Scrolls Online und so wie ich das beobachtet habe, ich habe ja schon eine ganze
Weile nicht mehr gespielt, hat sich Elder Scrolls Online mehr zum Singleplayer-MMO geändert
als zu einem eigentlich großen Open-World-Troop-Content-Spiel, aber da weiß ich nicht, wie das jetzt ist.
Ich habe lange nicht mehr gespielt.
In Diablo 3 kann mehr alles passieren als in Anthem und das ist ein Iso-Rollenspiel.
Was ich auch schwierig finde ist, eigentlich müsste BioWare auch an der Story noch mal
einiges schrauben, weil a. haben sie da auch viel versprochen, b. ist das auch ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal
von ihnen, das ist eigentlich ihre Stärke, das ist auch was viele von ihren klassischen
Fans erwartet haben.
BioWare konnte gute Storys hören.
Allein die ganzen Voice-Acts zu bezahlen, die Animationen für die Zwischensequenzen,
das ist unglaublich viel Geld, was das verstehen würde und am Ende ist Story der Punkt, der
am wenigsten Spieler zurückbringen würde.
Das kann sein.
Da hat er Recht.
Weil die müssen einmal das Fundament, was sie geschaffen haben, was glaube ich nicht
besonders gut ist, aufbauen, ich weiß nicht, ob man da noch was Cooles draus machen kann,
keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube das Wichtigste ist wirklich Gameplay, gutes Gameplay schaffen.
Das scheint auch ihr Fokus zu sein, Story erwähnen sie ja nicht mal in diesem Entwickler-Poster.
Ich bin immer noch überrascht, dass das Game wirklich rein handwerklich, sieht das wirklich
gut gemacht aus.
Was Leute, wenn sie von Anfang an gut gewesen wäre, drin hätte halten können.
Weil du vielleicht sagst, okay, das Endgame ist vielleicht nicht so geil, aber durch die
Story finde ich diese Welt so cool, dass ich da gerne drin bin, aber jetzt hast du
wahrscheinlich Recht, dass es...
Ich finde bei diesen Servicegames, ich meine, man muss sich auch hier nur wieder die Konkurrenz
angucken, was bringt denn die Leute immer wieder zurück zu einem Warframe, was bringt
die Leute immer wieder zurück zu einem Diablo, was bringt die Leute zurück zu einem Destiny.
Die Story von Diablo 3 war auch gerade schlecht.
Es ist einfach nur, weil diese Spiele eine sehr solide Gameplayboot haben, weil es Sachen
zu ergrinden gibt, weil der Grind Spaß macht, würde ich sagen.
Also ich finde, Destiny, der Grind macht Spaß, bestimmt nicht jedem, aber ein Großteil
der Community.
Das ist der Grund, warum Leute Destiny...
Ja Moment, Destiny, Moment, wir müssen mal wieder, unser wöchentliches Sache, Stadia,
Destiny Player Count.
Ohhhhhhh.
Moment, von wann ist das?
Von wann ist das?
Das ist viel zu hoch.
27.
Dezember, das ist zu hoch.
Das ist mittlerweile viel weniger.
Das ist viel weniger.
Wie hieß dann, wie hieß dann dieser Bot nochmal?
Destiny Bot, irgendwas Charles oder so?
Ah nee, wie hieß dann dieser Bot?
Stats Website, wo man schön gucken konnte, wer auf welcher...
Wer auf welcher Plattform spielt, wie hieß der irgendwie Charles, Charles, noch was?
Ach hier, das da, das da, Destiny, Stats, hä?
Besteuern, war das ne...
Äh, wo ging das nochmal?
Hier?
Hier, da, hier oben ist Stadia, guckt mal, null Prozent, Leute, ich zoome euch ran, dass
ihr es besser seht.
Hier.
Also, Stadia, Spieler, man erkennt das gar nicht so wirklich, da reicht die Auflösung
von diesem Graf hier für dich, denn das ist insgesamt, also, hm, ich würd nicht sagen,
dass der Stadia Player Count irgendwie hoch geht, ja.
Also, ich vermute mal, dadurch, dass das null Prozent ist, wird das abgerundet werden, also
sprich, das ist unter null Komma fünf, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass sie
es ab null Komma fünf aufrunden würden, also sagen wir, es ist unter null Komma fünf.
Leider gibt's hier, glaube ich, keine Zahlen insgesamt an Spielern, sondern nur die Verteilung.
Also, falls jemand ne bessere Statistikseite kennt, müsst ihr mir sagen, ich weiß, ich
kenn nur die, wenn wir jetzt die insgesammte Player Count wissen, also sprich, es ist irgendwas,
ich sag mal, um ne Million, ja, ungefähr um ne Million, und das heißt so, 990.000 Spielen
auf allen anderen Plattformen und 10.000 auf Stadia oder so.
Das ist halt der Witz, obwohl Stadia eines der Aushänge-Lounge-Titel, Destiny eines
der Aushänge-Lounge-Titel war mit Stadia.
Toll verkackt.
Da gibt's coole Sachen zu erfahmen.
Was ich schon toll finde, dass es im Destiny-Video so oft andere Spiele gezeigt werden, im Anthem-Video
so oft andere Spiele gezeigt werden, was im Prinzip, ja, gerade das heißt, das Anthem
ist sogar schon zu zugucken langsam ist.
Hast du schon vom Teaser für den Battle-Royale-Mode in Modern Warfare mitgekommen?
Ja, hab ich, aber ich hab ihn noch nicht geguckt.
Hat einer mal ne Link?
Dann gucken wir uns den noch an.
Bist du froh, dass du dann Stadia gecancelt hast?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Ich würde es gern mal ausprobieren und ich probier es wahrscheinlich auch mal aus mit
dem Chrome.
Und was mich auch eher interessiert hat, ist, ob man nicht irgendwie Custom-Firme auf das
Gerät, auf diesen Chromecast vielleicht draufklicken, dafür was anderes Gutes verwenden kann, aber
ich musste Stadia cancelen, ich musste.
Ich konnte es mir einfach nicht geben, dass bei einem Produkt, was man vorbestellen kann,
was sich Founders Edition nennt, dass es drei Wochen nach Release kommen sollte.
Das hab ich nicht eingesehen, ich musste das cancelen.
Ich cancel ganz wenig.
Wie sieht es eigentlich bei Teaser aus?
Ich hab ewig kein Teaser gespielt.
Immer so die Atmosphäre der Welt und sowas wichtig und persönlich leg ich sehr viel
Wert auf Story, aber du hast objektiv recht, die meisten Service-Game-Spieler sind nicht
so wie ich.
Ich meine, ich spiel ja auch gerne so, jetzt spiel ich Diablo 3 auch nicht mehr für die
Story, sei mal ehrlich.
Ich spiel Diablo 3 gar nicht mehr.
Die Story war auch immer nicht so der Hammer, die Cutscenes waren geil, Diablo 2 hatte eine
gute Story, aber du hast da natürlich recht.
Naja, also komm, die Story von Diablo 2 war jetzt auch nicht der Wahnsinn.
Ich mein, ich bin alt genug, ich bin wahrscheinlich ungefähr in seinem Alter, vermute ich nicht,
mal mit 34, 35, ähm, Diablo 2 hatte für die damalige Zeit halt eine coole, düstere Story
mit für die damalige Zeit halt coolen Zwischensequenzen, also im Prinzip ein bisschen das, was Diablo
3 in der heutigen Zeit hat, ähm, jetzt wirklich herausragend war die Diablo 2-Story nicht.
Finalen Punkt vielleicht, wie schätzt du denn die Chancen ein, dass Anthem 2.0 nochmal
eine Hochzeit für das Spiel einläuten kann?
Ja, also jetzt muss einfach BioWare abliefern, ähm, für mich sind das bisher einfach nur,
für mich ist es einfach nur ein bisschen PR, bla bla, hatten wir in der Vergangenheit
schon genug geschaut.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und wie du gesagt hast vorhin, das müssen jetzt Taten folgen, äh, ich würd's mir wünschen,
weil ich hätte wirklich Lust nochmal ein gutes Anthem zu spielen, ein motivierendes Anthem
zu spielen.
Ich will Anthem gar nicht spielen.
Und ich würde mir die Frage stellen, wieso hat sich jetzt EA entschlossen nochmal nicht
einfach Anthem fallen zu lassen und zu sagen, ok, das war's, wir machen jetzt irgendwie
ein Anthem 2, dann muss ich es mir nochmal neu verkaufen.
Weil sie hoffen, ein bisschen wie bei Fallout 76 aus den verbliebenen Leuten noch ein bisschen
Kohle rauszukriegen.
Die wollen, die wollen irgendwie gucken, dass, dass, dass nicht komplett das Desaster ist.
Alter, was mit dem ist am Auge los?
Also wenn das mein Auge, wartet mal, wenn das mein Auge machen würde beim Spielen, dann
hätte ich echt ein Problem.
Und, äh, ich glaub, da muss man zu zu zu origin access gucken.
Alter, was mit dem ist am Auge los?
Okay, weil der Monitor explodiert ist, ist es auch sehr ungesund.
Er hat geszoomt, genau, Enhance hat er gemacht, Enhance.
von der Division und vielleicht denkt sich ihr...
Division ist auch so ein Game. Leute, ehrlich, ich mein's, ich will's nicht
thrashen oder flamen zu sehr. Spielt jemand von euch Division 2 und wie ist das?
Weil für mich, ich habe in den ersten Teilen ein bisschen mit dem Famian
gespielt, für mich ist das auch so ein typisches Ubisoft Game, so nach diesem
nach diesem 0815, mittlerweile muss man das ja sagen, nach diesem 0815 Ubisoft
Gebiete erobern, Punkte einnehmen und auch irgendwie ein Spiel, was sich sehr
seelenlos anfühlt.
Neues da machen, versuchen wir noch mal mit Anthem. Das ist glaube ich ein guter
Punkt, weil wenn es funktioniert, so eine Art von Service Game ist ja genau das,
was Leute in so einem Pass auch hält und es ist dann auch noch so, dass Leute auch
nicht unbedingt sich jetzt Anthem neu kaufen müssen, wenn sie, wenn das jetzt
noch mal gefixt wird, weil das, weiß ich nicht, ob viele Leute das noch machen
würden, aber wenn du es eh schon in deinem Pass drin hast, guckst du vielleicht noch mal rein.
Ja und vielleicht lässt du den Pass weiterlaufen.
Eine gewisse Userbase ist standardmäßig vorhanden und ich glaube, dass ein weiterer Punkt dabei, vielleicht bin ich da auch
zu idealistisch, vielleicht überschätze ich den, aber ich glaube, wenn ein Studio, wenn
ein Publisher wie EA, und das wird schon eine Weile her, aber ein Studio wie BioWare kauft,
dann kaufen sie ja nicht nur talentierte Entwickler, sie kaufen einen
prestigeträchtigen Namen, wo sie auch dann sagen können, guckt mal, das nächste
BioWare Spiel, damit wirkt man dann. Und ich glaube, wenn du jetzt gesagt hättest,
also der Name ist eh schon beschädigt durch Mass Effect Andromeda davor, wenn du jetzt
aber gesagt hättest, okay, Anthem war kein großer Erfolg, wir stampfen es
einfach ein, dann wäre dieser Name BioWare so hart beschädigt gewesen, dass
für EA da auch ein Teil ihrer damaligen Kerninvestition, dieses Studio zu kaufen,
also sehr den Bach runtergegangen wäre, weil du hättest nicht mehr das
Prestigestudio BioWare in deinem EA Katalog, du hättest das Studio BioWare, das
dieses scheiß Service Game gemacht hat, auf das niemand Bock hatte und das wir dann
eingestampft haben, als es nicht genug Geld verdient hat.
Frag mich, das ist eh nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis BioWare nicht gemacht wird.
Aber den Namen behalten, so weiter und so weiter und so fort, du wärst da
richtig schlecht dargestanden und ich glaube manchmal überschätze ich so diese
Ruf- und Prestige-Wirkung, aber ich glaube gerade EA ist auch nach der Battlefront
Geschichte vielleicht ein bisschen sensibilisierter, unternimmt ja auch ein paar
Schritte in letzter Zeit, hat wieder ein Singleplayer-Spiel gemacht.
Angeblich ist sogar Battlefront 2 mittlerweile ganz gut spielbar und hat Battlefront ja
sogar gerettet, was finde ich auch noch mal ein schöner Beweis ist, dass es
eigentlich immer geht, also bei allem Pessimismus über Anthem, du kannst fast
immer, wenn du nur genug reinsteckst, alles noch retten, No Man's Sky, Battlefront 2, alles.
Da muss ich dir vollkommen recht geben, also ich hoffe auch, dass das EA
wirklich jetzt nicht, sich auch wirklich sagt, okay, der BioWare-Name muss wieder zu seinem
einstigen Ruhm, sag ich mal, verholfen werden, oder heck, fünf Monate, danke schön.
Ich hoffe, dass das EA auch da, wie bei Battlefront 2, Ressure rumreißen kann, ich würde es mir wünschen, wäre cool.
Ich persönlich auch, weil ich immer noch das immer mache.
Wisst ihr, was mir nicht gefällt, ein Trend, der mir überhaupt nicht gefällt?
Auf der einen Seite finde ich das gut, dass so Sachen wie Rainbow Six gut laufen, also sprich,
oder auch Battlefield 4 und sowas, dass die Sachen, wenn sie in einem scheiß Zustand rauskommen,
nicht komplett eingestampft werden. Das finde ich ja prinzipiell ganz gut.
Dankeschön Heinrich, fünf Monate, Twitch Prime, Huge Prime Sub.
Das finde ich ja eigentlich ganz gut. Ich finde plus den Trend nicht gut,
Spiele rauszukotzen heutzutage, vollkommen egal, in welchem Zustand sie sind,
und sich darauf zu verlassen, ah ja gut, wir können das ja danach noch irgendwie gerade biegen.
Wo sind wir hingekommen, dass heute quasi Early Access AAA Spiele, von der Qualität her und vom Fertigungsstand,
teilweise Early Access als veröffentlicht wird. Das finde ich keine gute Entwicklung.
Ich mag immer noch das Versprechen von Anthem, und ich hatte durchaus Spaß in dem Spiel, so ist es ja nicht.
Ich fand es einfach so, mal ein, zwei Kämpfe zu machen, so als cooler Mech da rumzischen,
ein bisschen ballern und so, das hat Spaß gemacht. Also ich mochte so das Grundkonzept,
so dass du ein Mech mit Zauberkräften bist.
Hast du das Games-Video zu Wolzen Wolzen gesehen? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe es aber mitgekriegt, das ist die, wo sie gesagt haben, sie haben ihnen angeblich die falsche Testversion geschickt,
und im Nachhinein muss man ja sagen, das Spiel ist trotzdem noch sehr verbackt.
Ich habe Dan's Gaming geguckt auf Twitch, und bei ihm ist das Game, vom Wechsel auf Akt 2 zu Akt 3,
hat seine Story-Progression zurückgesetzt auf Anfang Akt 2, anstatt auf Anfang Akt 3.
Von daher drücke ich da auch wirklich die Daumen, und ich mag ja auch, ich will ja auch, dass BioWare wieder BioWare wird.
Also ich will ja wieder, das ist überhaupt, Anthem ist eigentlich nicht die Art von Spiel, die ich von denen mag,
aber ich will, dass BioWare wieder der Name wird, der es mal war.
Wobei ich finde, Anthem war schon immer ein schlechter Fit für BioWare.
Das stimmt. Ja, da gebe ich ihm recht.
Ein gut getriebenes Spiel, das beißt sich mir so mit so einem Story-Ansatz.
Generell verbinde ich BioWare auch jetzt nicht mit rumfliegenden Mech-Shooter-Dingern.
Können ja auch gute Spiele so entstehen, nicht das, was ich direkt von BioWare will, aber kann ja funktionieren.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Anthem geredet. Wir drücken ihm die Daumen.
Jetzt interessiert uns natürlich noch, was ihr davon haltet. Kann euch Anthem 2.0 zurückbringen?
Irgendjemand im Chat hat gerade geschrieben, das Game hat so viele Seele wie das letzte CoD oder Overwatch.
Beim CoD gebe ich dir recht, aber eins, kann man Overwatch wirklich nicht vorwerfen,
dass es nicht irgendwie herausstechen würde, dass es keine Seele hat, bzw. dass es irgendwie nicht seinen eigenen Flair hätte.
Das hat Overwatch definitiv. Overwatch hat aber andere Probleme.
Das kann man Overwatch wirklich nicht vorwerfen.
So, und was wollten wir jetzt noch gucken?
Modern Warfare Battle Royale.
Oh Gott, das war ja...
Das hat echt noch gefehlt jetzt.
Nach was muss ich denn da gucken?
Teaser?
Oder nach was muss ich da suchen?
Stream kaputt? Nee, ich sag bloß nix.
Oh!
Oh, MonkaS.
MonkaGiga.
Unity Media wieder. Unity Media. Oh Gott! Unity Media.
Oder Twitch, eins von beiden.
MonkaS.
Was ist da los?
Unity Media, please.
Ich blende das jetzt so lange ein, bei Unity Media, bis es funktioniert.
Das backt immer noch rum, ich seh es genau.
Das backt immer noch rum.
Das ist DSLine, ja genau.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, heißt das, ich habe einen öffentlichen IPv6 und eine private IPv4.
Also... Moment.
Ich hoffe mal, dass das Ganze wieder funktioniert.
Als Hintergrund, warum ich das machen will, ist, dass ich mein NAS und Raspberry extern erreichen will.
Das kannst du nicht machen. Geht nicht.
Du hast keine Chance.
Zumindest über IPv4 deine NAS von außen erreichbar zu machen.
Was du machen kannst, ist, das kannst du über IPv6 machen.
Weil der Unterschied von DualStack zu DualStack Lite ist, äh Schwachsinn.
Der Unterschied von DualStack zu DualStack Lite ist, dass du bei DualStack eine externe oder eine Public IPv4 hast
und eine echte IPv6 Adresse.
Zwei ganz normale externe IPs.
Bei DualStack Lite ist es so, du hast nur eine IPv6 Adresse und dein IPv4 Traffic wird getunnelt über IPv6.
So, wenn du jetzt umstellst komplett auf IPv6, kannst du, äh wenn dein Endgerät, von dem du auf dein NAS zugreifen willst von extern,
auch IPv6 kann, kannst du direkt zugreifen.
Funktioniert. Mit IPv4 hast du überhaupt keine Chance.
Das Problem ist, wenn du auf IPv6 umsteigst komplett und manche Seiten nicht IPv6 können, dann gehen die Seiten nicht.
Aber zum größten Teil, die meisten größeren Seiten und die meisten Seiten sollten eigentlich mittlerweile mit IPv6 gehen.
Aber es gibt bestimmt genug Sachen, die einfach nicht funktionieren werden.
Also du hast die Auswahl zwischen Pest und Cholera. Du hast die Auswahl zwischen, du stellst einfach IPv6 um.
Du kannst super von extern auf dein NAS zugreifen.
Funktioniert. Firewall-Freischaltung machen gut ist.
Dafür hast du das Problem mit Seiten, die du benutzen willst, die kein IPv6 können.
Bei wie vielen Seiten ist das? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert.
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar mittlerweile besser, als ich mir das vorstelle.
Oder das andere, du hast keine Chance zuzugreifen von außen auf dein NAS.
Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst, wenn du irgendwo die Möglichkeit hast, einen externen Server zu betreiben, kannst du dich tunneln.
Du kannst dich tunneln quasi über IPv4, über den DSLite-Tunnel auf deinen externen Server und von dort dann wiederum zurück auf dein NAS zugreifen.
Das funktioniert. Dünn DNS geht doch. Nee, nee, nee.
Das Problem ist keine DNS-Auflösung. Das Problem ist, dass du mit IPv4, dass dein IPv4 terminiert auf einem NAT-Router deines Providers.
Und auf dem Router bzw. auf dem NAT-Endpunkt deines Providers kannst du halt keine Portweiterleitung einstellen, weil du da keinen Zugriff drauf hast.
Manche dünn DNS-Tunneln doch von IPv4 zu IPv6. Das hat nichts mit dünn DNS zu tun.
Ok Leute, Unity Media spakt wieder rum.
Jetzt wieder. Also Leute, ich lasse das jetzt so lange hier eingeplandet mit Unity Media.
Shit. Guck mal, was die schlechte Auflösungen haben.
Ich lasse das jetzt so lange eingeplandet, bis das Stream wieder funktioniert.
Genau, also um es nochmal zu sagen, wahrscheinlich habt ihr das gar nicht mitgekriegt, weil das Stream rumgespakt ist.
Also Easykiller hat gesagt, manche dünn DNS-Tunneln doch von IPv4 zu IPv6. Das hat mit dünn DNS nichts zu tun.
Ein Tunnel ist wieder was komplett anderes.
Also mein Provider hat das Angebot für 2€ im Monat mehr eine öffentliche IPv4 zu geben. Ich schätze, das ist einfacher als die Möglichkeit.
Ja, würde ich machen, habe ich bei Unity Media auch. Unity Media hat mich ein bisschen skamast.
Ich bezahle 2,99€ im Monat noch doppelt, also 2x 2,99€. Also ich bezahle im Endeffekt auch nochmal 2,99€ für eine externe IPv4-Adresse bei Unity Media,
dass ich jetzt richtig echten Dual Stack habe. Dual Stack Lite ist eine komplette Zumutung.
Guten Morgen, im Rahmen meines Physik-Tunnels haben wir gerade Python ein kleines bisschen gelernt. Und ich habe das Gefühl,
dass viele richtige Informatiker Python eher belächeln. Woran liegt das genau? Weil es überhebliche Dappen sind.
Da gibt es nichts zu belächeln. Python hat seine Stärken und Schwächen wie jede andere Programmiersprache auch.
Steam läuft wieder. Wo planen? Das klingt wie ein Emote von mir. Wo planen?
Der Schreibt bei uns ist umgedreht. Die Telekom kackt die ganze Zeit, wenn Unity Media läuft. Es kommt auf die Region an.
Herzt390 sagt, hier wird das ganze doch erklärt. Was wird dann hier erklärt? Und was geht es überhaupt?
Was wird erklärt? Was genau hat das mit dem Thema zu tun, was wir eben besprochen haben?
Okay, hören wir mal rein, was der Meister der Betonung von sich gibt hierzu. Der spricht die Sachen immer so super korrekt aus.
Und bei Unity Media müsst ihr euch dann auch auf euren Router connecten. Der spricht das alles immer so super korrekt aus.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt, wie Sie das Pi-Hole eventuell doch im eigenen Netzwerk nutzen können.
Pi-Hole hört sich halt irgendwie schon ein bisschen unanständig an vom Namen her.
Ihr Router ist eigentlich nicht zulässt, dass Sie das Pi-Hole im eigenen LAN als DNS Server bekannt machen.
Okay, also wer auch immer das Video gerade gepostet hat, Herzt390, das hat mit dem Thema, was wir gerade diskutiert haben, absolut gar nichts zu tun.
Okay, wollen wir das trotzdem gucken? Es geht nur 6 Minuten. Da kann ich meinen Senf dazu geben.
Ich glaube, es ist ein deutsches Video. Ja, sieht so aus.
Komm, 6 Minuten können wir trotzdem gucken. Ich finde, das ist ein ganz guter Channel. Kann man mal zeigen.
Das Video geht zurück auf viele Nutzer, die uns geschrieben haben, dass Sie das Pi-Hole nicht nutzen können, weil zum Beispiel die Unity Media Connect Box genau das eben nicht zulässt.
Das ist natürlich die grundlegende Vorgehensweise, damit die eigentliche Hardware nicht zur Verfügung steht.
Warum haben die Leute das Problem, dass sie ihr DNS-Gedöns nicht... Nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe.
Weil es manche Router gibt, vor allem die Dinge, die du vom Provider kriegst, wo man keinen Custom-DNS-Server eintragen kann.
Oder was ist das Problem? Vermute ich mal. Dr. Evil Cookie sage ich auch gleich was zu.
Und kann man diesem Unity Media Router nicht wenigstens beibringen, welchen Upstream-DNS er verwenden soll?
Alternativ kann man einfach auf seinen Clients selbst einstellen, welchen DNS-Server sie nehmen sollen.
Oder man verteilt das über DHCP. Mal gucken, was er vorschlägt. Es gibt verschiedene Varianten, was man machen kann.
Deep ist halt immer das Gleiche. Die Frage lautet, wer sorgt für Ordnung im LAN?
Das ist immer der sogenannte DHCP-Server. Der spricht die Sachen so geil aus. Der DHCP-Server.
Wenn Sie mit Ihrem Computer oder Handy sich im LAN oder WLAN anmelden, dann brauchen Sie bestimmte Informationen vom Netzwerk oder Router.
Zum Beispiel gibt mir eine freie IP. Wie lautet die Gateway-IP, damit ich ins Internet kann? Und eben wie lauten die DNS-Server?
Jeder Router, auch vor Kriegsmodelle, hat einen eigenen DHCP-Server an Bord. Glücklicherweise hat auch unser Pi-Hole einen DHCP-Server.
Der Pi-Hole ist ein großer DHCP. Ach, sorry. DHCP, nicht DNS. Aber hat es auch.
Wie ich eben schon sagte, erklärt der DHCP-Server allen Geräten, unter anderem den DNS-Server.
Wenn wir nun den DHCP-Server im Router, also in der Connectbox, abschalten können, dann schalten wir einfach den DHCP-Server im Pi-Hole ein und wir sind wieder im Rennen.
Kann man machen. Okay, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken. Das ist relativ naheliegend.
Das können wir uns sparen. Da ist jetzt nichts großartiges Neues für uns bei.
Geht das Stream noch? Ja, gut, sehr schön.
Also, wir wollten uns den Modern Warfare Battle Royale Teaser angucken.
Wo, wo, welcher, was ist der richtige, Leute? Das da?
Ist das Terminal? Ja, sieht ein bisschen aus wie Terminal.
Okay.
Wird das wiederbelebt? Erstmal gerätzt.
Ghost ist tot? Warum ist Ghost wieder da?
Weil sie alles ausschlachten müssen, was irgendwie da ist.
Hä? Oh Gott, es ist Battle Royale-Modus. Oh fuck, ey.
Das haben wir jetzt echt noch gebraucht. Muss das sein? Hat das die Welt gebraucht?
Hat da die Welt drauf gewartet? Ich weiß ja nicht.
Na gut, wem's gefällt, warum nicht? Warum nicht, warum nicht?
Da bin ich schon schon on. Drei Stunden schon, ich bin da ganz schön lang heute.
Gab's nicht schon Battle Royale in Black Ops, doch, doch, klar.
Ich bin ja auch schon mal auf Black Ops.
Heute wollen wir uns noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 Top Plays angucken.
Ich finde das immer sehr entspannend. Und wir wissen ja schon,
im Prinzip könnten wir das Ganze ohne seinen Commentary gucken,
weil er eh immer das Gleiche sagt. Und wieder dieselben Kommentare, na klar.
Oh, das war ein nicer Snipe. Oh, ein huge, huge Berg im Hintergrund.
Wahnsinns, Wahnsinn.
Auch noch einen doppelten hier, auch noch hier einmal Kollateral über die halbe Map.
Ne, über die ganze Map. Aber er hätte schon mal 360 machen können davor.
Also das kann ja jeder sonst.
Das ist das richtige Video. Okay, also zeig mal her.
LAN erreichen trotz DS Lite. Okay Leute, das gucken wir uns mal vorher an.
Da kann ich nämlich meinen Zenf dazu geben.
Das müssen wir uns trotzdem mal vorher angucken.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt eine einfache Möglichkeit
für IPv6 Dual-Stack-Lite-Kunden ihr Heimnetzwerk zu erreichen.
Und für alle, die jetzt noch nicht wissen, was denn das Problem mit Dual-Stack-Lite ist.
Der ist so geil, der die Pause immer macht. Für alle Kunde, die mit Dual-Stack-Lite-Problem sind.
So geil.
Ganz kurz grafisch dargestellt. Das ist das normale LAN, also ihre Geräte und ihr Router.
Router. Die Aussprache. Das ist so geil. Inhaltlich sind die Videos meistens gut.
Ich finde die Aussprache einfach immer so geil. Ihr Router.
Wenn Sie mit dem Handy mal draußen sind und wollen zum Beispiel auf die Nextcloud in Ihrem eigenen LAN zugreifen,
dann geben Sie im Grunde über die App zum Beispiel die IP Ihres Heimrouters an
und schon sind Sie im eigenen Netz. Haben wir schon hundertmal in anderen Videos gezeigt.
Wenn du Port-Weiter-Reitung hast, schon.
Natürlich, es gibt das Problem der sogenannten dynamischen IP, in der Sie von Ihrem Provider regelmäßig eine neue IP...
Das ist eine andere Aussprache vom R. Der sagt dem Motto Router.
Rammstein würde eher sagen Router.
Die rollen das eher. Der rollt das nicht, der errert das irgendwie so.
Also die Nummer, die jetzt hier beispielhaft gezeigt wird, mit am Ende 7.139,
die ändert sich eventuell alle 24 Stunden. Dafür gibt es aber entsprechende Dynamic DNS Dienste.
Haben wir auch alles schon gezeigt insoweit. Man kommt relativ einfach...
Er schnurrt es, ja, so ungefähr.
Jetzt kommen die Kunden, die eigentlich vom Provider eine IPv6 bekommen.
Das ist quasi die IP der Zukunft.
Aber die Provider haben nicht ganz alle Hausaufgaben gemacht.
Deswegen müssen wir die Grafik jetzt hier ein bisschen abändern.
Denn streng genommen sitzen wir gar nicht mit unserem Router direkt im Internet.
Das stimmt.
Es ist eher so, dass wir im Lahn des Providers sitzen.
Das Ganze würde also eher so aussehen.
Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Internet-IP.
Am Ende immer noch die 739.
Und hier sind die anderen Kunden des gleichen Providers eben mit mir in diesem Provider-Lahn.
Und alle Geräte gehen dann am Ende an diesen Router, der quasi beim Provider steht.
Und dann geht es erst ins Internet.
Da das Netzwerk aber ein vollständiges IPv4-Netzwerk ist,
würde entsprechender Traffic, den ich eben jetzt hier an...
Äh...
Ist das so?
Reden wir jetzt von IPv6 oder 4?
Weil mit Dual-Stack-Lite ist das meines Erachtens nach nicht so.
Wartet mal kurz, Leute.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ähm...
Also, aber auch...
Aber auch bei IPv4...
Ist das...
Ja doch, doch.
Bei IPv4 ist das so.
Genau.
Wenn man jetzt nicht von DS Lite ausgeht,
sondern wenn man rein mal von IPv4 ausgeht,
dann ist das so.
Allerdings wird hier nichts genattet an der Stelle.
Sondern man hat wirklich eine richtig echte gültige IPv4-Adresse.
Nur, dass halt der Next-Hop eine wirkliche,
nur dass halt der Next-Hop ein Provider-Router ist.
Das ist aber vollkommen normal.
Irgendwie muss man ja...
Ist das nicht Carrier-Create-Nut?
Nee, das hier noch nicht.
Das hier sieht nicht Carrier-Create-Nut aus.
Mal gucken.
Das Problem ist jetzt, IPv4, es gibt nicht genug Zahlen,
weswegen einige Provider eben, um den Mangel auszugleichen,
IPv6-Adressen verteilen.
Und wenn alles IPv6 wäre,
dann wäre das auch kein großes Problem.
Das heißt, mein Router, der bekommt jetzt eine IPv6-Adresse.
Router?
Übrigens, mir ist aufgefallen, das Ganze funktioniert doch so nicht.
Äh...
Also, je nachdem.
Wenn die Dinger wirklich im gleichen Netz wären,
dann...
müssten alle an dem gleichen Router hängen,
weil du kannst...
Also, was du bei einem Router nicht machen kannst, ist,
du kannst nicht das gleiche Netz an zwei Interfaces haben.
Zumindest nicht so ohne Weiteres,
weil ein Router ist dafür da, von einem Netz ins andere zu routen.
Und wenn du das gleiche Netz an beiden Interfaces hast,
dann weiß der Router nicht, was er machen soll.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das geht dann immer nur aus einem.
Also, dafür ist es im Router nicht gelten.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, je nachdem, wie es gewallen habe,
ist das richtig.
Ich habe übrigens übelst Hunger.
Und dafür bekomme ich die.
Und im kompletten Provider-Lan
ebenfalls alles IPv6-Adressen.
Jetzt wird es natürlich den einen oder anderen geben,
der schon in die Kommentare geschrieben hat,
wo soll hier das Problem sein?
Dann wird einfach eben die IPv6-Adresse in der App angesprochen
und schon leitet der Router hier alles durch.
Ja, das würde so sein, wenn der Provider IPv6-Dual-Stack
ohne das Light gewählt hat,
denn sein Provider IPv6-Lan hier
ist nur über IPv4 an andere Netzwerke angeschlossen.
Ja, das ist natürlich dann fail.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass du bei Unity Media
eine wirklich von außen erreichbare IPv6-Adresse hast?
Ich bilde mir einen schon.
Das Problem ist nur,
wenn dein Endgerät kein IPv6 kann,
dann musst du über IPv4 gehen
und dann hast du das Problem.
Und der Router hier
ist mehr oder weniger genauso konfiguriert
wie ihr Heimrouter.
Wenn jemand von hier aus
auf ihr Handy zugreifen wollen würde,
dann wird ihr Router in der Standardeinstellung natürlich sagen,
nein, hier kommt keiner rein.
Ich bin ja so eine Art Firewall-Schutz
der eigenen Geräte.
Und genau das Gleiche ist auch hier.
Wenn Sie jetzt eben dieses Gerät hier ansprechen wollen würden,
dann wird der Router hier sagen,
ich lasse hier keinen rein.
Genau wie in Ihrem Router.
Wenn Sie hier rein wollen, von zu Hause aus,
dann müssen Sie in Ihrem Router eine ganz spezielle Ausnahme konfigurieren,
dass eben die Daten reingelassen werden.
Das Problem ist,
das stimmt schon,
aber wahrscheinlich kannst du es auch nicht tiefgreifend erklären.
Das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr,
wenn du einen Nutt hast,
gar nicht so sehr,
dass der Router
das irgendwie aktiv blocken würde
oder so.
Der Router hat schlicht und ergreifend keine Ahnung,
wo du hin willst.
Also stellt euch mal vor,
lassen wir mal das ganze IPv6-Gedöns weg.
Verangenehm,
du willst
von deinem Endgerät hier drauf,
auf dein Notebook.
Du sprichst von deinem Endgerät,
wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus,
dass hier eine öffentliche IP,
du würdest diese IP ansprechen,
dann hat der Router keine Ahnung,
dass du eigentlich zu dem willst,
weil woher soll der Router das wissen?
Deswegen brauchst du ja Portweiterleitungen.
Umgedreht ist es kein Problem,
von innen nach außen,
aber von außen nach innen,
dein Router kriegt das Paket,
der weiß nicht wohin,
es gibt keinerlei Informationen darüber.
Deswegen braucht man Portweiterleitungen.
Umgedreht ist es kein Problem,
von innen nach außen,
von innen nach außen greift man von einer privaten IP
auf eine Public-IP zu,
das kann sich das NAT merken
und erkennt das dann an die Antwort,
passend zu dem, der die Anfrage gestellt hat.
Aber umgedreht,
wenn quasi die Verbindung aufgebaut werden soll,
von außen nach innen,
hat man keine Ahnung, wo was hinschicken soll.
Den man dann auch entsprechend konfigurieren müsste,
mit einer Weiterleitung,
der ist natürlich nicht konfiguriert,
den können sie auch nicht konfigurieren,
weil auf dem können sie gar nicht zugreifen.
Der Provider könnte den konfigurieren,
macht er aber nicht.
Wozu auch die Arbeit. Deswegen.
Da ist also das Problem.
Aber dafür gibt es ja NG-Rock.
Um das Ganze jetzt hier praktisch zu zeigen,
habe ich mich jetzt hier mal auf
meinen Raspberry Pi...
...nicht mehr verwendet.
Ich habe halt das Glück,
dass ich meine lifetime IPv4-Adresse
bei dem
schlechtesten Provider
aller Zeiten habe.
Mit der schlechtesten VM aller Zeiten.
Aber für 35 Dollar lifetime
eine IPv4-Adresse gekriegt habe.
Und alles, was ich tunneln müsste,
tunnle ich immer über meinen Server
per SSH. Ganz easy.
Einfach über die externe IP
getunnelt.
Im SSH-Tunnel.
Port-Weiterleitung. Gut ist.
Also man kann ja
mit SSH wunderbar
sogar Ports weiterleiten. Von aus nach innen.
SSH kann alles.
Und
die entsprechende Durchleitung,
die lege ich mit NG-Rock
unter NG-Rock.com.
Ich brauche da einen Account,
den habe ich jetzt hier schon erstellt.
Ich erst mal nebenbei was.
Im ersten Login steht hier direkt die
Infektionsanleitung dabei.
Ist relativ einfach.
Für meinen Pi
muss ich jetzt hier die Software runterladen.
Machen wir das hier mal ganz schnell.
Die Datei wird ausgepackt.
Es gibt ein paar solcher Dienste.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
dass man das öfters braucht.
SSH hat aber viel
mehr overhead beziehungsweise niedrige Bandung.
Das stimmt.
Man hätte auch mal einen Anzip machen können.
Die entsprechenden Befehle sind alle in der Webseite.
Das ruckelt aber.
Es gibt ein paar solcher Services.
Man kann auch bei SSH sogar sagen,
für solche Zwecke will man die Verschlüsselung ausschalten.
Ist er im richtigen Verzeichnis?
NGROCK!
Der Name!
Das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr verwendet.
Das ist ggf.
.
das für ein krasses rummige Tunnel der ganze Scheiß ist.
Du hast intern IPv4, das wird eingepackt über IPv6 an Unity Media.
Unity Media macht dann Carrier Create NAT, schickt dich per IPv4 wieder raus.
Das heißt, dieser Tunnel ist auf jeden Fall immer dazwischen.
Dort gehst du weiter auf den N-Croc-Server, machst einen Port auf,
worüber dann die Antworten wieder zurückgetunnelt werden.
Das ist voll für'n Arsch, dass das überhaupt notwendig ist.
Cloud hatten wir in dem entsprechenden Video angesprochen.
Dann lieber 2 Euro im Monat bezahlen für eine Public IPv4 und IPv6.
Unbedingt, dass man über eine fremde Domain darauf zugreift.
Deswegen kennt Nextcloud die sogenannten vertrauten Domains in der Konfigurationsdatei.
Und wenn wir da nicht drinstehen, dann funktioniert natürlich der Zugriff auf den Web-Server.
Aber Nextcloud lässt sich nicht bedienen.
Deswegen jetzt hier ganz kurz...
Ja gut, das müssen wir uns nicht mehr angucken.
Ja, das kann man machen.
Gibt ein paar Wachen, die man sich da durchtunneln kann.
Aber gucken wir uns mal weiter, Battlefield 4.
Hast du Unity Media?
Ja.
Du musst Power-Upload buchen bei Unity Media, aber schreib den Twittersupport an, die sind
immer schnell.
Wer in Linux, wer unter Linux mal kurz seine SSH, äh, nicht seine SSH, seine Shell-Session
sharen will, der kann das hier verwenden.
Das ist auch ganz praktisch, das da.
Instant Terminal Sharing.
Da kann man einfach seine aktuelle Shell-Session freigeben.
Auch über so einen Sharing-Link ist auch recht praktisch.
Das ist doch gestellt, oder?
Das ist doch gestellt.
Warum steht der Typ so blöd da und macht nix?
Das ist doch, also das ist doch gestellt, oder, Leute, ernsthaft, was macht der Typ da?
Der schießt nicht, der fliegt einfach nur, dass er gesniped werden kann.
Er hat einen absolut perfekten Kopfschuss.
Weiter geht's, es ist Bruno Santos und ich habe eine Frage für dich.
Normalerweise, wenn ich einen Klick sehe, der etwas schade ist und ich nicht sicher bin, ob
die Person einen Art Ausfluss oder am schlimmsten einen Scherz oder ein 3rd-Party-Software nutzt,
tendiere ich sie nicht zu.
Diesen, allerdings, sieht komplett möglich aus.
Er zählt an Spieler, die gespottet sind.
Er zählt an Spieler, die gespottet sind, weil er auf dem Retticle genau wo zu zählen ist.
Das ist komplett okay.
Aber nur etwas über den Klick und das Fakt, dass er drei Klicks von genau dem gleichen
Ort auf der Battlefield 3 gespottet hat, ich weiß nicht, ich denke, es ist wahrscheinlich
okay.
Ich mag es, dass die Spieler den Bedürfniss haben, aber lasst mich das unten wissen.
Ihr wisst mich immer.
Ich tendiere nicht, Klicks zu zählen, weil ich nicht sicher bin.
Und wenn ich nicht sicher bin...
Guck mal, die stehen da einfach nur rum und machen nix.
Die stehen da einfach nur rum, machen nix und gucken in seine Richtung.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Dies, allerdings, könnte ein legitimate Klick sein und sowieso sieht es ziemlich beeindruckend aus.
Ne, die stehen einfach nur hin und rum und machen nix.
Er zählt an Spieler, die gespottet sind, weil er auf dem Retticle genau wo zu zählen ist.
Headshots auch für die Mehrheit dieser Schüsse, was absolut verrückt ist.
Das ist legitimate, das ist einfach unglaublich.
Strictlich kein Sniping-Clip, denn ja, es ist ein Tank, aber der Range, den er erreicht hat,
ist unglaublich.
Okay, das war, das war, eigentlich hat er prediktet, der fliegt jetzt runter.
Okay, der schießt dahin und er hofft, der fliegt jetzt runter.
Hat er aber nicht gemacht.
So, und dass der da jetzt trifft, das ist definitiv Glück.
Was ist denn das für ne Sniper?
Ah, die China-Sniper.
Ist das Battlefield 3 oder 4?
Ich erkenne es gar nicht mehr genau.
Was ist es denn, Battlefield 3?
3?
Gab es so viele chinesische Waffen in Battlefield 3?
Das Talah-Market.
Weil die Chinesen gab es in Battlefield 3 doch gar nicht.
Und was gab es denn für Fraktionen in Battlefield 3?
Es gab diese Terroristen-Fraktionen, es gab die Amis, es gab Franzosen, glaube ich, ne?
Ach, kalt.
Russen und Amis, ja.
Mehr net?
Okay.
Gab es nicht?
Gab es nicht noch diese Terroristen-Fraktionen da?
Epi-Sniper.
Okay.
Just a tad, he actually gets himself another very nice Sniper.
Wären die jetzt schnell gewesen beim Switchen, hätten sie an den Pilot sitzwischen können.
Achtung, es kommt mit einem etwas ungewöhnlichen Video, auf Operation Metro, der eine Semi-Auto-Sniper-Rifle mit der QBU geht.
Wir haben nicht mehr so viele Leute, die in Klips senden, das ist so schade.
Ich wollte diese Episode ausführen, aber es ist unfair, die Leute in Klips zu senden,
um sie für mehr als zwei oder drei Wochen warten zu können.
Ich glaube, diese Waffe habe ich nie gespielt in Battlefield 3.
Auf jeden Fall nur Russen und Amis. Kann sein, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Was hat man auf Terran Highway gespielt? Hat man da auch Russen und Russen aus Amis gespielt? Echt?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das für eine Waffe ist.
Ich habe die nie gespielt.
Und ich habe relativ viel Battlefield 3 gespielt.
Auch Aftermaths und alles.
Ach, die waren nur im Single-Tower, okay.
Siebertower.
Wisst ihr, mich hat das immer, wie gerade, so was von den Wänden.
Die Optik von Siebertower hat mich immer an Mirror's Edge erinnert.
Obwohl ich weiß, das erste Mirror's Edge war nicht mal Frostbite.
Das war doch Unreal 3, glaube ich. Aber ich finde, die Optik von Siebertower hat ein bisschen was von Mirror's Edge.
Guckt euch das mal an, so die Wände und so. Das könnte auch aus Mirror's Edge kommen.
Das liegt, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich daran, dass Gebäude und Wände in Mirror's Edge ausgespielt werden.
Dass Gebäude und Wände in Mirror's Edge auch sehr glänzend sind und sehr wie geleckt aussehen.
Das ist da halt auch so in dem Fall.
Mirror's Edge, generell Wände, Häuser, sonst was, alles Büros, sehen halt sehr glänzend aus.
Und so richtig porrentief rein, so richtig wie geleckt.
Die Magno hat sich auch geil angefühlt, wenn er mit eingetroffen hat.
Allerdings hatte ich immer das Problem im Battlefield 3 mit langsam feuernden Waffen, dass die Hit Detection oft mal so verzögert war.
Du hast dann geschossen und hast gedacht, Alter, der ist jetzt doch, der muss doch jetzt down sein.
Und dann irgendwie eine Sekunde später ist er dann aufgenommen.
OP!
Den habe ich auch fast, ich habe fast nur ein 16 mit MP16 gespielt bei OP.
Aber was spielt der mit 15 FPS oder was ist da los? Guckt euch mal an, wie sehr das rumleckt.
Er rettet immerhin, da habe ich aber Glück, sonst dürfte ich dieses Video an euch zeigen.
Du wolltest was zum Media-Server sagen, schreib nochmal, ich habe es nicht mehr in der History.
Spass!
Die Gegner sind wieder hängen geblieben.
Mir fällt immer wieder auf, wenn ich Battlefield 3 und teilweise auch viel Clips sehen, wie gut sich das Game auch einfach anschauen lässt, obwohl das 10 Jahre alt ist oder so.
Gar nicht ganz, aber fast.
Man kann es einfach gut angucken.
Hätten die dann mal Squad Rush zu einem ordentlichen eSport-tauglichen Modus ausgebaut?
Ich sage es immer wieder, die müssen einfach nur ein gutes Squad Rush bringen.
Das wäre ein richtig guter Modus, eine richtig schöne Kombi aus dem, was die Leute aus Rainbow Six können, aus dem, was die Leute aus CS kommen.
Squad Rush ist einfach etwas, was ich, finde ich, mehr wie jeder andere Modus in Battlefield für eSport eignen würde.
Vor allem, weil es kein Aufguss ist von einem Modus, den es schon in anderen Games gibt.
Sondern was eigenes ist, was Battlefield auch gut repräsentiert und man auch gut umgesetzt richtig schön zuschauen könnte.
Ich wollte ein paar Tipps haben, worauf man achten muss, wenn ich Medien wie Fotos und Filme in meinem WLAN zur Verfügung stellen möchte, was sich halt angeht.
Als erstes natürlich mal ein ordentliches WLAN-Passwort.
Und ansonsten, du musst den Dienst ja aufmachen.
Du willst ja darauf zugreifen.
Du könntest, sofern es einen Router hergibt, natürlich noch einstellen, wenn du mehrere WLANs, mehrere LANs und sonst was hast.
Wer genau darf, welches Netzwerk darf, welches Netzwerk nicht darf.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, du willst vom WLAN in das WLAN zugreifen, also quasi von Geräten im WLAN auf den Säuber, der im WLAN steht oder eine IP aus dem WLAN hat.
Das Einzige, was du noch machen könntest, ist, bei einem ordentlichen WLAN-Passwort, du könntest so Geschichten machen wie ein Mac-Adress-Filter, wobei das halt nicht wirklich das sichere macht im eigentlichen Sinn.
Aber es macht es halt ein bisschen komplizierter.
Was du machen könntest, ist auf dem jeweiligen Server, wo du das Ganze laufen lässt, also aufbleib nass, ich würde halt gucken, dass ich dort alle Ports dicht mache,
die nicht notwendig sind für den Fileserver.
Also ich würde dort, wenn es keine Ahnung ist, wenn eine Raspberry Pi mit einer Platte dran ist und da läuft was drauf, ich würde alles dicht machen,
ich würde SSH dicht machen, ich würde alles dicht machen außer den Fileserver und nur Zugriff erlauben aus dem internen Admin-Netz.
Achso und dann eine dicke USB-Platte an den, ach du willst die Platte an den Router machen?
Oh da kann ich dir nichts zu raten, das habe ich nie ausprobiert, ich weiß nicht, was die Fritzbox dafür Möglichkeiten bietet.
Gescheites WLAN-Passwort dürfte wahrscheinlich das wichtigste sein.
Ich weiß, dass es keinen Unterschied macht mit der MAC-Adresse.
Kann man aber machen, ich sage ja, dass es wirklich bringen tut es eigentlich nichts.
Es ist ein ordentliches Passwort, ansonsten fällt mir da auch nicht allzu viel ein.
Und wenn du es auf ein extra System machst, wie gesagt, falls du eine Raspberry hinstellst mit einer Platte oder so,
ich würde alles dicht machen, außer den Port, also lokal auf dem jeweiligen Gerät, würde ich alles dicht machen, was du dicht machen kannst.
Ich würde irgendwie IP-Tables einschalten oder, wie heißt das neue?
Nicht IP-Tables, wie heißt das? Nee, ich habe vergessen wie das neue heißt.
Alles dicht machen, außer vom Admin-Netz aus, außer dem File-Sharing-Port, den du brauchst.
Wie heißt denn das Ding? Tables, Nachfolger, NF-Tables meine ich.
Die Fritzbox ist auf jeden Fall kein gutes NAS. Das schafft irgendwie 3 oder 4 MB die Sekunde, wenn überhaupt.
Das ist wirklich lahm. Der USB-Anschluss und generell das Ganze, es ist eher eine Funktion, die RVM zur Verfügung stellt, weil es geht, nicht weil man sie benutzen sollte.
Also NAS über Fritzbox ist keine gute Idee.
Dann stellt ihr lieber einen Raspberry Pi hin, der auch zwar nicht wahnsinnig gut ist für NAS, aber zumindest hin kriegt Gigabit halbwegs, halbwegs Gigabit zu zättigen.
Oh, da sind deutsche Spieler, da hört man sie.
Na nein, als wenn hier jemand rum und ins Treppen war.
Spielst du überhaupt noch was, Maxia? Aktuell hauptsächlich das da.
Ich reine mir den Hintern wund in Path of Exile.
Die Map, die Map war nice.
Das ist doch Rush, oder?
Weil der ist doch Defender. Der pusht gerade in den Spawn, der Attacker rein.
Ja, das ist so ein Fail in Battlefield 3, dass das in dem ausmacht, wirklich mal. Guckt euch mal Grand Bazaar an.
Oder TDM? Ah, TDM. Okay, dann ist gut.
Weil das ist auch die gleiche Stelle, wo man Rush spielt, am Anfang. Schon von Wolsten gehört, ja, habe ich das ziemlich verbackt.
Das war ein bisschen problematisch. Denkt mal, die Rush spawns in Grand Bazaar.
Das war auch mal eine Lieblingswaffe gewesen in dem Game.
M416, Westin.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Die Gegner sind wieder komplett planlos.
Boah, das ist cool. Das ist auch wie das Setup, die Gegner stehen einfach so dumm rum und bewegen sich nicht.
Na gut, der liegt halt einfach da und kämpft sich einen ab.
Spielt eigentlich die andere TDM-Maps noch irgendjemand?
Außer, ich meine, es war doch von Anfang an immer noch Sharkannels.
Selbst Close Quarters wird kaum noch gespielt.
Ich muss aber langsam eine Waffe aufheben.
Du hast keine Muni mehr.
Oh, die sind low, die kannst du schön wegsprayen.
Das Battlefield 3 ist schön anzusehen.
Du kannst in dem Game die Leute so ultra zerstören.
Boah, da hat er aber Glück gehabt, dass er das überlebt hat.
Boah, die Taschenlampen, die Taschenlampen, hat er schon wieder voll verdrängt.
Aber man merkt, dass er lange noch ein bisschen in einem Roost wird auf seinem Streak.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Schöner Clip.
Leute, ich hab noch was zu essen da.
Wir gucken einfach noch ein Battlefield-Video.
Zumindest den Anfang.
Wir gucken erst einmal 5 Minuten Battlefield, bis ich fertig gefuttert bin.
Und dann gucken wir noch was anderes.
Wobei, eigentlich...
Oh, ich bin schon ganz schön lang on.
Oh nee, das Stream hat rumgespackt.
Ich seh's.
Ich bin schon fast...
Ich bin 3.
Oh nee.
Stream.
Jetzt wieder.
Wir lassen es jetzt schon mal auf.
25 Minutes of Best Footage.
Ist das Konsole?
Nee, oder die Auflösung ist zu hoch für Konsole.
Aber das ist Blur.
Aber warum hat er Blur?
Was ist da los?
Boah, wie soll das gesprayt werden?
Alter, kriegen die aus dem Maul.
In your face.
Spielt er mit Blur?
Allen Ernstes?
Warum spielt er mit Blur?
Keiner der Leute, die gut sind.
Spiel mit Blur?
Warum?
Oder ist das gar kein Blur?
Liegt das daran, dass er mit mehr FPS spielt?
Oder...
Nee, ich glaube, das liegt an der...
Entweder an der Aufnahme.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Motionblur drinne.
Entweder liegt das an der Aufnahme oder an dem...
Ähm...
Wie er das gerendert hat vielleicht.
Na, du kannst ja in Vegas beispielsweise auch Zwischenbildberechnungen machen.
So, ich weiß nicht, ob das Blur ist der...
Aber doch.
Das ist...
Das müsste Blur sein, der in Game entsteht.
Weil irgendwie so Sachen wie hier Waffen und so, die Kanten sind auch verschoben.
Das müsste schon in Game Blur sein.
Wobei...
Der Killfeed...
Nee, der Killfeed...
Oder?
Der Killfeed...
Aber guck mal, hier unten verzerrt nix.
Vielleicht ist es doch Post-Processing Blur.
Ist ja auch egal.
Die Musik dabei.
Ja, stehen soll aber weggespreit werden.
Oh, Slow-Mo-Effekt hier.
Ich mein ganz ehrlich, so ein Feeling, wo es um dich übelst...
Das hatte ich außer in Battlefield 3 und teilweise 4 in keinem...
Battlefield Company 1, 2...
Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4.
Danach hatte ich das nicht mehr.
So geile Dinger hier.
Vor allem, das war ja gar kein DLC, das war ja bei Release dabei.
Obwohl es DLC hieß.
Wisst ihr, was ich gut finde?
Dass der Typ gar nicht dabei kommentiert.
Ist mir sogar viel lieber, ohne das Commentary von dem Kerl dabei.
Max, warum so wenig Viewer?
FeelsBatman.
Die Musik im Hintergrund passt zu Null zum Gameplay.
Oh, Metro.
Das war auch eine Sache, die Battlefield 3 richtig gut gemacht hat.
Das Movement über die Map.
Von dunklen bis hin, Sliden bis sonst was.
Permanent drauf.
Wohnt sich das noch?
Mittlerweile nicht mehr, die Server sind ziemlich leer.
Wir gucken mal.
So, Hessenfetch, wir gucken mal kurz.
A BattleLocker.
BF3, was es da noch so gibt.
Server, Server, Browser.
Es ist kaum noch Spieler drauf.
Es gibt Rush Classics.
Mixed Modes, das wäre der einzige Server für mich hier.
Rush Classics.
Was soll ich denn filtern?
Nach was soll ich filtern?
Ich hab gar keinen Filter an, das müsste doch eigentlich alles sein.
Wir können nach allem filtern.
Ah, Hä?
Rush.
Spielt Squad Rush noch irgendjemand?
Rush, es gibt, es gibt.
Gut abends, abends kriegt man vielleicht 3 oder 4 Server voll.
Jetzt ist ja Mittags.
Kriegt man vielleicht 3 oder 4 Server voll, aber das war es dann auch.
Mehr gibt es nicht.
Okay, komm, eine Sache gucken wir noch.
Was haben wir denn hier noch Schönes?
Things you can make from old dead laptops.
Was soll man aus alten Laptops machen können?
Man kann aus dem Display, kann man so einen Projektor machen?
Da war ich aber schon immer zu faul dafür.
Was kann man aus alten Laptops sonst noch so machen?
Ich mein für einen Server ist wahrscheinlich jeder Raspberry Pi besser geeignet als ein alter Laptop.
Nicht unbedingt von der Rechenleistung her, sondern einfach weil es keinen Laptop rumstehen braucht.
Gucken wir mal, wir gucken uns mal an, was man alles aus dem alten Laptop machen kann.
Produktiv.
Na dann zeig mal.
Hipp.
Das war das war noch die alten massiven Sinkpads hier mit Metall Scharniere und sowas.
Die waren richtig stabil.
Damit kannst du Leute erschlagen im Zweifelsfall.
Sehr laut am Start.
Das wäre mir viel zu anstrengend schon den ganzen Kram auszubauen.
Wie hat er das Sinkpad überhaupt so kaputt bekommen?
Wahrscheinlich hat er das schon kaputt gekauft und wenn nicht vielleicht ist er dann drüber gefahren.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, eine Sache wie man das tatsächlich kaputt kriegt, so wie das ist, wenn du es auf die Erde gelegt hast.
Also mal angenommen du hast irgendwie eine Werkstatt oder irgendwas oder irgendwo wo es einfach nur unordentlich ist.
Was auf die Erde gelegt, es liegt halt was drunter, sodass es quasi schräg liegt und du trittst drauf.
Dann kann es schon durchbrechen.
Ich habe noch ein Notebook von 2008, das einzige Notebook, wobei, doch, ne, ne das ist neuer.
Bass.
Slap like.
Was ist das für ein Controller, den er da hat?
Mach mal den Finger weg, spiel sehen was das ist.
Man sieht es nicht, hat man das vorher gesehen, was es für ein Controller ist.
Ich sehe nichts, ich sehe nicht was das ist, was ist das?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich will wissen, was da für ein Controller drauf ist, weil von der Antenne her sah es auch aus, als ist da W-Lan drauf, onboard und alles.
Es sieht ganz okay aus, muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen, es sieht okay aus.
Es geht glaube ich hier eher darum, dass man halt was draus bauen kann.
Wenn man wirklich USB, Bluetooth Lautsprecher haben will, die man an die Wand hängt, man findet bestimmt qualitativ deutlich besseres.
Für nicht viel Geld, wenn man, wenn man, sag mal mal so, selbst auf Aliexpress.
Und wahrscheinlich klingen die auch noch besser, aber dafür selbst gemacht, das ist echt okay.
Ja alter, so eine Arbeit reinstecken an scheiß Laptop Leute.
Ich glaube, wenn man wirklich solche Do-it-yourself Geschichten macht, da geht es auch mit um den Weg dahin, dass man das quasi gut hinbekommt.
Das ist genauso, wie ich hier im Haus meine Controller habe, beispielsweise im Keller, am Stromzähler und sowas.
Da habe ich auch sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich mir was fertiges kaufen können, aber es ist einfach nice, wenn man sieht, dass man ein schönes 3D gedrucktes Geäuse hat, selbst programmierten Microcontroller drinne und das funktioniert.
Wobei ich mir, nee, ich hätte mir nichts kaufen können, weil sowas individuelles gibt es nicht zu kaufen, fertig.
Ja, siehste Leute, hört sich doch gar nicht so schlecht an.
Kappa HD.
Was für ein 3D-Drucker hast du?
Ich habe einen i3-Megas habe ich.
Den da.
Den da habe ich. Ja, genau.
i3-Megas.
So einen Würfel habe ich da noch nie drauf gedruckt.
Wenn man so einen Würfel da drauf drucken würde, druckt das auch einen Monat oder so.
Diese Sorte von 3D-Druckern wären umso langsamer, umso größere Sachen man druckt.
Zufrieden, ja.
Für mich als 3D-Drucker noob, wunderbar.
Was machen jetzt, baut er ein Föhn? Will jetzt ein Föhn bauen?
Das ist überhaupt nicht warm genug dafür und nicht genug Luft.
Ah, der will LEDs kühlen.
Das ist tatsächlich keine blöde Idee.
Ich habe hier an meinem 3D-Drucker auch so einen Ring unten dran, dass ich im dunklen sehe, was er macht.
Ja.
Naja, ne.
Also ich habe mir bei AliExpress einfach so einen, sowas hier, genau.
Ich habe mir bei AliExpress so einen Ring bestellt, so ein LED-Ring.
Und das habe ich einfach mit Kabelbinder, sowas hier in der, sowas hier, sowas hier.
Sieht fast genauso aus.
Habe ich mir bei AliExpress bestellt und dann mit Kabelbinder, so hier, mit Kabelbinder unten an 3D-Drucker gemacht.
Und jetzt kann ich im dunklen sehen mit der Kamera, die daneben steht, wie weit er ist und wie es aussieht, weil es immer gut beleuchtet ist.
Die Frage ist, so was mache ich jetzt damit?
Ich habe gekühlte LEDs.
Und jetzt?
Nein, das sieht doof aus.
Das sieht nicht cool aus.
Das sieht doof aus.
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Oh, Repp.
Ja.
In der Grundlichtbeleuchtung halt.
Damit kann ich mich identifizieren.
Fake Window, größer, echtes Window.
Für weniger Kontakt zur Außenwelt.
Was?
Das finde ich ganz hübsch.
Ich meine, sowas gibt es fertig zu kaufen bei AliExpress für 250 wahrscheinlich.
Aber sieht trotzdem ganz cool aus.
Da kriegst du ja Gopfel bei.
Oh, so ein Ding habe ich mir gekauft, Leute.
Das war eines der letzten Werkzeuge, wo ich noch nicht hatte.
Vor zwei Wochen habe ich mir einen gekauft hier.
Noch nicht einmal benutzt, aber haben.
Ja, ich wollte Tremel vermeiden zu sagen, weil Tremel ja im Prinzip nur ein Hersteller ist davon.
Der hat man den Kram wohl erfunden.
Es ist aber schwierig, danach zu suchen.
Weil im Englischen nennen sie das Rotary Tool.
Im Deutschen heißt das dann Multitool, aber Multitool gibt es halt ganz viele.
Oh, da braucht man ja ewig für.
Das ist das zu filigran für mich.
Es sieht aber schon ganz cool aus.
Ich finde es sieht ganz cool aus.
Ich brauche es nicht unbedingt, aber es scheint ganz cool aus.
Nein, ich weiß ja nicht.
Das sieht schon ziemlich behelfsmäßig aus.
Vor allem, wie knapp sind das jetzt zusammen.
Wie dieser Laptop mit den sieben Monitoren.
Das ist halt ein bisschen Overkill.
Erstmal Koffer einpacken für das Notebook.
Ja, optimal für das mobile Arbeiten in der Bahn.
Damit bist du auf der Lan der King.
Man macht heute keine Lans mehr.
Preise, Preise gibt es dazu übrigens nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so teuer, dass sie sich gedacht haben.
Das können wir den Leuten nicht gleich erzählen.
Das Ding klauter kann man machen.
ein mikrofon
now huge huge
quali mikrofon wahrscheinlich
proof of which is that the little
lavalier mikrofon that i'm wearing right
now was made out of a laptop
mikrofon that disassembled several years
ago and it sounds so good that i've just
used it in almost every video i've
made since then so that's
how good they can potentially
sound now as most of you
won't have a use for a little lavalier
mikrofon i will instead be showing you how
to make a little clip-on communication
mikrofon that you can
clip onto your headphones and use
for extremely clear calls or even
communicating well with your
big brain self-made headset
making this is quite simple
gibt's eigentlich neue
muss man gleich mal gucken
gibt's eigentlich neue modmics
ich hab die sache jetzt nicht mal so verfolgt weil diese mittlerweile
so unglaublich
teuer geworden sind
ähm
ja mit
mikrofon
so sehen die jetzt aus ok
die sind schon krass teuer geworden
mittlerweile ey
ähm
ich hab noch das alte modmick was
einfach nur ein äh ja
so in diesem preisrikon was einfach auch
sehr gut in der lecke hat
ähm
so eins da
der richtung hab ich aber ich hab noch
modmick 3 glaube ich ist das
die hören sich nicht wahnsinnig gut an
aber für
in game kommunikation
und auch für sprache
vollkommen ok und man kann halt
kopfhörer seiner wahl
verwenden
das ist halt echt praktisch ja
weil ich sag's immer wieder gaming headsets sind zum größten teil
oder halt richtig teuer
ähm
wenn man gutes haben will
die beste
kombination ist immer noch ein guter
kopfhörer und wenn man dann
modmick
yes
zeiss
d
van
sp
Das ist die Behandlung der Amplifikation, die sowohl den overallen Volumen, als auch die Reaktionsschwindigkeit des Autogain-Kontrollers hat.
Dieser Autogain-Kontroll kann den Volumen reduzieren, wenn der Input zu laut ist.
So, du wirst nie wieder Sound-Klipping bekommen, wenn du mit ihm reden willst.
Wenn er aufgelöst ist, kann er in einen Computer-USB-Port und Mikrofon-Input ausgestattet werden,
und er wird als ein gutes Sound-Budget-Microfon ausgestattet werden.
So, wie klingt es?
Ich glaube, es klingt ziemlich gut.
Wir haben sonst nichts anderes zu tun an Ingen.
Ja, das Zahlmann-Mikro, das geht, aber das klingt wirklich nicht gut.
Also, wenn du nur Hosen beleidigen willst in CS, dann ist das Mikrofon okay.
Warum hat er so eine gute Quali damit?
Ja, weil die Platzierung ganz gut ist.
Ich würde sagen, die Platzierung ist ziemlich gut.
Weil er ein echter Hacker ist, genau.
Ganz ehrlich, Sprache aufnehmen, so ein ganz normales Gelabere in einem halbwegs normalen Raum,
das kann man mit fast jedem Mikro machen.
Das hört sich mit allem ganz okay an.
Wenn man das dann aber mal vergleicht, wenn man die Stimme von ihm zum Beispiel mal hört,
wenn man das mit einem ordentlichen Mikrofon aufgenommen hätte, dann sieht man erstmal den Unterschied.
Da hört man den Unterschied.
Oh, jetzt wird die Hex auf. Jetzt ist das Ding aber kaputt.
Also, wenn du das aufmachst, ist in der Regel das Ding im Arsch, hat er ja auch gerade hingeschrieben.
Auf die Idee muss man erstmal kommen.
Ein Festplatten-Schleifer.
Die Idee ist so abgedreht, dass ich die schon wieder cool finde.
Nee, da reicht Pfeifert nicht aus. Da braucht man mindestens Sixhead.
Shiny.
Was für ein Game ist das, wo irgendein In-Game-Fisch die ganze Zeit sagt, oh, shiny.
Axos, nee, glaub nicht.
Warum?
Jetzt, Leute, ich sehe schon jetzt wirklich Exploding Brain angesagt.
Was, es laggt?
Unity Media, bitte.
Was machen die bei Unity Media dann wieder?
Ich kann nichts dafür, Leute.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es an Twitch liegt.
Ihr seht ja da unten, ob es funktioniert oder nicht. Es funktioniert nicht.
Ich bin voll am Abspacken.
Haben wir das heute noch mal, Unity Media?
Nee, nee, das ist keine Minecraft Musik, das ist die Epic Chillstep Collection 2020.
Oh, jetzt ist es RIP.
Leute, es ist vorbei.
Manchmal hilft ein Router-Restart. Ich mache jetzt garantiert kein Router-Restart.
Nur weil es Unity Media nicht gebacken kriegt.
Ich mache ein Router-Restart, wenn ich dann, wenn ich dann off gehe.
Stimmt, wie war diese Seite noch mal? Alle Störungen oder so?
Oh.
Trifile.
Endlich lohnt sich mein neues Emote. Scheint wieder zu funktionieren.
Okay, scheint wieder zu gehen.
Okay, dann gucken wir das Video mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Was, wie der F?
Ist wieder kaputt?
Geht wieder.
BastiW, bei mir gibt es kein Gigabit, sonst würde ich das auch machen, aber gibt es nicht.
Noch nicht, okay.
Was bastelt der da?
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Ah.
Das sind die gleichen Dinger, die man auch in E-Cigaretten reinmacht.
Das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Also die Dinger, die können echt ordentlich in die Luft fliegen.
Oder auch so eine einzelne Zelle.
Genau.
Vor allem, du brauchst vor allem auch das, was das Chargen ausmacht und so.
Also das Handling von Akkus ist gar nicht so ohne.
Jetzt eigentlich ein neues Elektroboot-Video, ja? Gab es vor ein paar Tagen.
Vor allem ist das unglaublich ineffektiv, je nachdem, was du für Controller betreibst, weil die meisten Controller sind ja intern. 3,3 Volt, das ist total...
Das ist über USB und...
Dieses Ding für die Wand fand ich ganz cool, aber die Lampe, nee. Vor allem hat die dann auch noch, dann hat die auch noch einen Lüfter dran.
Skippen das jetzt mal kurz.
Das Problem bei den Dingern ist, du hast ja keine Möglichkeit, Nachtsicht und sonst was zu machen.
China wird hellhörig.
Nee, ein großer Vorteil von Billy-China-Cams ist ja, dass du da zumindest für Indoor eine gewisse Nachtsicht-Funktion eingebaut hast.
Wisst ihr noch, wo wir Motion-Detection mit OpenCV programmiert haben? Was erstaunlich gut funktioniert hat?
Ich könnte mir glaube ich nichts Schlimmeres vorstellen, vor allem wegen dem Display nicht zum Spielen gedacht.
Ihr seht tatsächlich cool aus, aber dafür kann ich mir einen Shield-TV hinstellen oder einen 30 Euro Firestick.
Oder wer's do-it-yourself komplett machen will, stellt sich einen Raspberry hin, wobei halt geschwindigkeitsmäßig ist das Shield-TV das beste, was man sich aktuell ins Wohnzimmer stellen kann.
Was gibt's? Es gibt wirklich Leute, die keinen PC haben, aber schon einen PC wollen?
Die meisten älteren Leute, die ich kenne, die keinen PC haben, die wollen keinen PC.
Und alle, die einen PC haben wollen, die haben eigentlich einen.
Und die meisten älteren Leute, die keinen PC haben, die haben eigentlich einen.
Und alle, die keinen PC haben, die haben eigentlich einen.
Die Framerate-Stats sind immer noch ein großer Teil der Geschichte.
Dieser klassische Novigrad-Rund zeigt die Range, die ein normaler Switch auf Standard-Clock geht.
Außerhalb der Stadt gehen die meisten Spots über 30 FPS.
Auch Galloping auf voller Geschwindigkeit zeigt...
Dadurch, dass die Auflösung relativ hoch bleibt, heißt das auch, dass es eindeutig CPU limitiert hier in der Stadt.
Um das Spiel nur flüssig mit einer Kappe zu halten. Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Wenn es genug Headroom gibt, um viel höher zu gehen als etwa 35 FPS, dann wird die GPU-Fuhr anstatt die Resolution auf 720p zu erhöhen.
Und das macht irgendwie Sinn, oder? Um die Imagequalität zu fokussieren und die meisten Switch-Ressourcen zu machen.
Dieser Niveau der Adaptabilität ist notwendig, um in diesem Spiel zu funktionieren, um in jedem Szenario zu adjustieren.
Jetzt werde ich euch zeigen, was passiert, wenn ihr die Dynamic Resolution Scaling, oder DRS, komplett auslöst.
Wie es aussieht und wie es die Performance beeinflusst. Aber wird es auch auslöschen?
Die Standard-Switch-Clocken haben keine Probleme, eine solide Framereinheit zu halten.
Das ist mit klaren Exzeptionen. Klar sind Bereiche wie Novigrad eine Schwierigkeit.
Das große Npc-Volumen, das im Vergleich zu PS4 und Xbox One immer gleich ist, ist ein Problem für das 1Ghz-Clock-CPU.
Die Compiler können ja auch für ARM-Bineries erzeugen.
Ich denke, sie werden so angepasst haben, dass das eben lauffähig ist.
Es wird nicht einfach gewesen sein, je nachdem, was du für Spezialitäten der jeweiligen Plattform verwendest.
Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das große Problem an der CPU-Architektur liegt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Low-Level-Geschichten, wo sie von Hand CPU-Instruktionen gebastelt haben, sich in Grenzen halten.
Die ganze Switch-Architektur dürfte eher das Problem sein, dass man mit den Limitationen zurechtkommen muss und deswegen sein Game anpassen.
Ich glaube, das eigentliche Lauffähig-Machen auf der Plattform war gar nicht in Ordnung.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es lauffähig ist.
Ich meine damit, dass es einfach startet und dass man es spielen kann, dass das gar nicht so der große Akt war.
Aber das Spiel anzupassen, so dass es eben erträglich läuft, dass das das eigentliche Problem war.
Und wir schauen auf 25 FPS.
Die hohe Zahl von Draw-Calls, Instruktionen an die CPU, um jedes Objekt zu renden, wird hier auch ein Problem sein.
Und es gibt natürlich keinen einfachen Weg, das zu verändern.
Es gibt nur wenig Zeit, um exklusive Emotes zu verdienen.
Guckt euch an, der Hype-Train.
Ich bin schon ganz aufgeregt hier. 94%.
Es gab was, Alter.
Ups.
Ja, dann mach mal. Moment, hat er jetzt sieben Minuten erzählt, dass er seine Switch übertanken wird und muss sie dann zwei Minuten lang zu übertanken oder was?
Das ist über gar kein Auferclock, das sind die normalen Specs.
Der Switch ist runtergetaktet.
Kann man den Hype-Train manuell deaktivieren? Keine Ahnung.
Nee, der sagt bloß, ich soll Abos verschenken, dass der Hype-Train erfolgreich ist.
Weil, Twitch UI auf Englisch, ja. Weil man browsert auf Englisch.
Ja, guckt Leute. 2-3 FPS höchstens. War klar, dass da keine Wunder zu erwarten sind.
Das ist klar. 2-3-4 FPS, genau das, was ich vermutet habe.
Da ist ja nichts grundlegend unterschiedlich jetzt. Es ist halt ein bisschen schneller.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Eigentlich ist klar, dass wir da keinen großen Unterschied sehen. Die Auflösung ist einfach nur höher.
Man müsste das ausschalten und mal gucken, was passiert.
Ja.
Die wilde Jagd ist 15 FPS und noch halb gewild.
Die Leggy-Jagd ist das.
Aber das dürfte am CPU übertaktet liegen, weil die Grafikkarte in Novigrad wahrscheinlich nicht das Limitierende ist.
Ich meine immerhin, die CPU ist 40% oder so schneller.
Oh man kann, das Ding hat Grafikoptionen.
Das ist so ein krasser Unterschied. Guckt euch das mal an.
Hier erkennst du alles. Hier sind auch Sachen geladen und hier ist...
...brei.
Guck mal, hier unten sind Büsche geladen, hier nicht. Und trotzdem ist es da hinten einfach...
Lang sind wir eigentlich heute schon an.
Oh ja, oh ja.
Guckt euch mal hinten die Viecher an. Das ist schon ein ordentlicher Unterschied.
Die dynamische Auflösung zu festen 720p. Das sieht schon deutlich weniger verschwommen aus wie das.
Ja, man sieht das schon. Dafür ruckelt es wahrscheinlich rechts.
Du kannst das, du kannst das glaube ich mit, du brauchst glaube ich den Premiums-Dash, aber nagel mich jetzt nicht drauf fest.
Aber guck lieber mal vor, ich weiß nicht.
Die Leggy-Jagd ist da.
Oder das Dash, du kannst im Trade-Channel wahrscheinlich rumspammen. Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich habe noch nicht getradet.
Du kannst dir aber auch das Starter-Pack kaufen für glaube ich 20 Euro. Das war glaube ich ganz gut vom Value her.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es noch nicht gemacht.
Ok, also jetzt ist es Standard-Clocks gegen Overclock mit festen 720p.
Das heißt jetzt sehen wir, was es wirklich für einen Unterschied macht.
Ja.
Die
Moment, es gibt schon irgendwelche Witcher 3 Switch Graphic Mods
Wahrscheinlich aktivieren die einfach nur Sachen, die schon im Game drin sind
Aber das Foliage-Setting ist extrem wundervoll. Es geht um eine der wichtigen Probleme, die ich in der Pop-in-Level hatte
Du bekommst vier Präsetten von Low zu Ultra, obwohl, behör dich, der Switch funktioniert an einem hohen Setting von Default
Und so ist der Schock für die Verbesserung nicht so groß wie man erwartet
Auch so, der Schock von Low zu Medium zeigt, dass der Schock auf dem Boden grösser ist, als auch die Renderung der Bäume auf dem Horizont
Und du siehst, dass nur ein wenig mehr Detail aufgeteilt wird
Eine Sache zu notieren ist, dass das der größte Performance-Hit der Settings ist. Wenn man von Low zu Ultra geht, verliert man ca. 3-4FPS
Aber das Drucken ist eh schon
Es ist trotzdem faszinierend, das Spiel so zu tun
Ein weiterer Schock, der eine tangible Veränderung macht, ist der Schärfungsfilter
Er ist populär in der Modding-Kommunikation und der Performance-Hit ist wirklich sehr minimal
Wenn man es auf und auf schiebt, werden die Kontraste hochgezettelt und auf einem nativen Settings
und auf einem nativen Settings
Es gibt einen Druck auf eine schärfere Image
Es gibt mehr Schimmer als Ergebnis, aber es ist ein guter Option, den Schock zu haben
Der Anti-Aliasing-Toggle ist auch da, wenn man sich den Schock auf den Boden nehmen möchte
Das ist nicht unbedingt empfohlen, aber es ist eine Option, wenn man den Schock auf dem Boden nehmen möchte
Und wenn man nicht mag, wie der Anti-Aliasing funktioniert
Jetzt, schließlich, gibt es Punkte, die ich wünsche, hier zu lösen
Zum Beispiel, wegen der Größe des Switches-Kartridges, bleiben Texture-Assets kompressiert als PS4
Obwohl es wenigstens auf diese komische Kartridge passt
Wir haben auch noch NPCs, die an einer niedrigeren Framereinheit unterwegs sind
Währenddessen ist Texture-Filterung auf der blöden Seite
Da muss ich immer an Assassin's Creed Unity denken, mit Low-FPS-NPCs, wo teilweise die Köpfe und die Körper von den NPCs nicht zusammengepasst haben
Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern, an Unity, wo die NPCs voll im Arsch waren?
Also der Unterschied ist wirklich groß
Also der Unterschied ist riesig
Guckt euch das mal an links und guckt euch das mal an rechts
Das sieht viel, viel, viel, viel besser aus rechts
Mit dem Unterschied, dass es wahrscheinlich grottenschlecht läuft auf der rechten Seite
Das sieht aus wie Majora's Mask, ey
Oder pixelig ohne Ende
Okay, mir fällt kein Vergleich dazu
Ich meine, 60 FPS, yeah
Aber wie das ausschaut, ey, das ist...
Mir fällt kein Vergleich dazu ein, weil die Sache ist die...
Effektmäßig und drumherum sieht es halt viel, viel besser aus als alte Games, ja
Aber auflösungs- und klötzchenmäßig sieht das aus wie irgendein uralter Metal Gear oder so
Ich bin ja jemand, für den sind generell mehr FPS, größer Grafik
Aber in dem Fall muss ich sagen, es sieht ja so schon nicht gut aus
Und so ist es unspielbar hässlich
Also, ich würde sagen, wir spielen es einfach weiter auf dem PC
Ja, wir spielen es einfach weiter auf dem PC
Ja gut, das ist in der Burg, da ist überhaupt nichts drumherum
Der Switcher
Das finde ich so geil, die NPCs in der Witcher, die schleichen immer nur um die Gegner rum
Auch die Gegner schleichen so um dich rum, na, Geralt geht da ab, so bam bam bam, hit hit hit, blub blub blub blub blub
Und die NPCs, d'dumm d'dumm, mal ein bisschen um das Monster rumschleichen, mal ein bisschen um das Monster, haha, einmal treffen, um das Monster rumschleichen, um das Monster rumschleichen
In der Zwischenzeit ist Geralt da am Start BAM BAM BAM HIT HIT HIT, weil er ja 5-2 im Kreis gedreht, der NPC hat 2-mal geschlagen.
Gut, also wir wissen jetzt, es lohnt sich nicht.
Und natürlich auch das betrifft Portable Play, solange man die zusätzliche Anzeige auf die Batterie erzielen kann.
Aber das ist alles, was ich heute noch habe.
Ich würde gerne hören, was ihr an dem Testen sehen wollt.
Wenn ihr noch was habt, schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
Und wenn ihr noch was habt, schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
See you!
Bye!